GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
TO TODAY'S SUNSET OVERSIGHT
HEARING WHICH IS HELD JOINTLY
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU AGAIN
TO ALL OF THE STAFF WAS MADE
THESE THIS WEEK OF HEARINGS
POSSIBLE INCLUDING ASSEMBLY
ROLES SERGEANTS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER A FEW
LOGISTICS ABOUT OUR HEARING
TODAY FOR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
DUE TO THE CURRENT STATE HOME
ORDERS WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL BE PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY
TODAY VIA WEB CONFERENCING
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS WITNESSES
LISTED ON THE AGENDA THEY MAY
BE BRIEF DELAYS AND TECHNICAL
ISSUES AT THE ASSEMBLY CONTINUES
TO ADAPT TO THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
TESTIFY REGARDING ANY OF THE
ENTITIES BEING REVIEW TODAY
WE'LL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
BASED ON THE ENTITY FOR WHICH
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
WE ASK THAT WHEN YOU CALL
IN ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE AND FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISHING TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE NOTE
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET
YOURSELVES AND UNMUTE YOURSELVES
AS WELL TODAY WILL BE HEARING
FROM THREE ENTITIES SUBJECT
THE SUNSET REVIEW THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT BOARD THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE AND THE BUREAU
OF REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS
WE UNDERSTAND THAT EACH BOARD
DEPARTMENT OR BUREAU MAY NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITIONS
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES
RAISED IN THAT CASE PLEASE
TO PROVIDE TO THE BEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE AN INFORMAL OR STAFF
LEVEL ANSWER SAID THAT THIS
COMMITTEE MAY BE BEST INFORMED
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH TECH
COUNTERPARTS ARE GLAZER FIRST
PARTNERSHIP THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS HAVING SAID THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO CHAIR GLAZER
FOR ANY INITIAL COMMENTS YOU
MIGHT LIKE TO MAKE SURE GLAZER
THANK YOU AT YOUR LEVEL IT'S
GOOD TO BE HERE I APPRECIATE
AGAIN THE GOOD WORK OF YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL AS OUR
SENATE STAFF AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COOPERATION FROM ALL OF
THE BOARDS AND BUREAUS THAT ARE
APPEARING BEFORE US TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR GLAZER ALSO
WANTED TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO OFFER ANY INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS AS WELL TO -- WITH
ANY MEMBER IN THE CHAMBERS
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME C. NINE WITH
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO IS
CURRENTLY -- WITH US REMOTELY
WITH ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
WISH TO PROVIDE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND SPEAK NOW
SEE I THINK THAT THERE ARE
NO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK WHO ARE
JOINING US REMOTELY WILL THEN
HEAD INTO THE AGENDA AND WILL
BEGIN THEN WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS THE REVIEW OF
THE PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS BOARD
ASSISTANT BOARD WE ARE JOINED
TODAY BY THREE INDIVIDUALS
OUR FIRST OFF IS ROSANA CON
-- THE INTERMIX ACTIVE OFFICER
JED GRANT BOARD PRESIDENT AND
CHARLES ALEXANDER VICE PRESIDENT
-- SO HAVING SAID THAT
WELCOME AB PLEASE WITH YOUR
INTRODUCTORY MARKS AND WE
BEGIN WITH OUR INTERMIX
INTRUM VICTIM OFFICER
FOR THE BOARD TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND SERVE
OUR LICENSEES PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS WHO ARE DEDICATED
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN THE COAL
BUT- A NINETEENTH AND THAT MAKE
UP WITH ME TODAY IS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT- JEN GRANT- DR
CHARLES ALEXANDER OF WOULD LIKE
PRESIDENT WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE
IT. BUT I'LL PASS THIS ON TO
THE BOARD PRESIDENT FOR US YOU
KNOW. THE OVERVIEW OF THE BOARD
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
ROSANA CHRISTIAN THAT. HELLO
YES MAYBE IF YOU GET SUCH KILEY
FOR A MOMENT SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISUALLY SEE YOU
AS WELL. WE'RE HAVING SOME.
DIFFICULTIES SO MAYBE JUST ON
ON THE SCREEN ARE YOU JUST AYE
DIALING IN NOW DO WE HAVE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS VIRTUALLY I
AM DIALING IN AYE I WAS HAVING
ISSUES WITH THE CAMERA. SENATE
YES OKAY. GREAT THEN BUT PLEASE
YES PLEASE IDENTIFY SOMETHING.
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE DIALING IN
AND NOT THE VIRTUAL SO PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANKS YES HELLO
THIS IS- JET GRANT I'M THE
BOARD PRESIDENT FOR THE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD-
MITCHELL MISTER GLAZER THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE THE REST
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
HELP. IN THAT AND- SECURING A
STATE PRACTICE FOR THE CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE ALSO BEFORE
I CONTINUE I AM CURRENTLY AWAY
ON MILITARY DUTY WITH THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD SO I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY CHAIN OF COMMAND-
IN PARTICULAR. MY BRIGADE
COMMANDER COLONEL GROENEWALD
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE EXCUSED
MY DUTIES TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THIS MEETING TODAY- SO- THE
FIRST THING I REALLY WANT TO
COME ON- IN A TWO NINE- THAT
ARE DYING FROM AN INDUSTRY TO
PLAN- THAT TALKED ABOUT-
ALTHOUGH WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
BOARD- WE'VE HAD A LARGE SHARED
SERVICES AGREEMENT WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE IN THE
STRATEGIC PLAN THE BOARD VOTED
TO MOVE TOWARDS A MORE
INDEPENDENT- POSITION FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD- ESPECIALLY
FOCUSED ON- OUR ENFORCEMENT-
PROCESSES REALLY WANTED TO
BRING THOSE IN THE HOUSE- OF
THAT MOSTLY HAS TO DO WITH THE
GROWTH OF THE PA PROFESSION
THERE'S ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND- LICENSE PH IN
CALIFORNIA NOW WHICH REPRESENTS
ABOUT 10% OF THE PA'S IN THE
NATION. AND SO THE BOARD TO AND
BOARD STAFF HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON ACCOMPLISHING
THAT TASK WHICH IS- A.
SIGNIFICANT- PIECE OF WORK.
ADDITIONAL LAST YEAR- CENTER-
SPONSORED SPC NINETY MORE IS
ONLY- BILL FOR PA. CAL THAT ARE
REALLY- ALONG OF THE- SCOPE
PRACTICE THE DEFINITION HAND UP
PRACTICE PARAMETERS- FROM- BE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT INTO. AN
AGREEMENT THAT IS REACHED AT
THE PRACTICE LEVEL BETWEEN A
PHYSICIAN IN PA- WHICH-
ESSENTIALLY WAS A REWRITE OF
OUR PRACTICE ACT. WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON- MANY OF THE
REGULATIONS- THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO FULLY IMPLEMENT
THAT BELL- BUT WE DID A LOT OF
WORK ON THAT SINCE OUR LAST
SUNSET REVIEW- AND THIS IS A
THIS BILL IS A REALLY GOOD FOR
OUR CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA
INCREASES- ACCESS TO CARE BY
ALLOWING PIERCE TO PRACTICE- TO
THE FULL EXTENT. OF THEIR
LICENSES- WITHOUT OVERSIGHT
THAT'S SPECIFIC TO THE- PA AND
PHYSICIAN AFTER PM POSITION
LEVEL. SO WE'VE BEEN- WORKING
QUITE. DILIGENTLY ON THAT ALSO.
YEAH APPRECIATE- STAKEHOLDER.
AND ESPECIALLY CENTER CARRIER
ON HURST AND WORKING ON THAT
BILL. SACRAMENTO OF COURSE THE
CODEPEN HAS RESULTED IN A LOT
OF- UNEXPECTED DEAD CHALLENGERS
AS WELL AS OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN HOW TO. MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE CONSUMERS
DURING A TIME OF CRISIS SO. WE
ADDED A LOT OF WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND- HAVING SOME EMERGENCY
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW THE
APPEARS TO BE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE- DURING
THESE TIMES. SO THAT THOSE ARE
THE SORT OF BIG ISSUES THAT
HAVE COME UP SINCE OUR LAST
CONCERT REVIEW. THERE'S BEEN
SOME- GROWTH IN THE BOARD- I
WANT TO RESPECT THE COMMITTEES
THAT TIME TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS OR
ELABORATE ON ANYTHING. BUT THAT
SET UP FOR THE MOST PART OF.
BEYOND THE BASICS OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS AND THE DIRECTION. THAT
WE'RE GOING WE'RE GOING FORWARD.
GREAT THANK YOU MUCH. AGAIN
THEY YOU VERY MUCH ALSO FOR
YOUR SERVICE ON THE BOARD AND
HER FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THE
BOARD AS WELL. HAVING SAID THAT
WILL THEN GET GOING TO
QUESTIONS FROM ANY. MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN. WITH
ANY MEMBERS IN THE ROOM
CURRENTLY WHO MIGHT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AND SO THIS WILL BE
THE TIME FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ARE CURRENTLY IN THIS ROOM NOW
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS TIME. K. SEEN THEME OF
SENATOR PAT. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DID HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING THE REPORT- THIS IS A
QUESTION I ASK- MADE THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BOARDS- REGARDING
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO I MAKE
NOTE THAT IN YOUR REPORT YOU DO
MENTION THAT YOU DO SOME
AUDITS- BUT YOU DON'T PROVIDE
STATISTICS AS TO WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE LICENSEES DO
YOU AUDIT EACH CYCLE AND TO
WHAT THE- AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THOSE AUDITS AND RESULTS
AND- FINDING THAT SOMEONE DID
NOT COMPLETE TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION. SO AND IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SHARE THAT INFORMATION-
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT
QUESTION- WE'RE HAPPY TO
COMMENT ON OUR- AUDIENCE FOR
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION.
SO APPEARS ARE REQUIRED TO
HAVE- ONE HUNDRED- HOURS OF
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION TO
MAINTAIN THEIR- NATIONAL.
CERTIFICATION THE FIFTY HOURS
OF THAT IS THAT CATEGORY ONE.
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
WHICH IS MORE FORMAL AND THEN A
FIFTY HOURS IS CATEGORY TWO
WHICH IS- LESS FORMAL. JOURNAL
STAND. WHAT MORE. AND OUR- THAT
MERE THAT REQUIRE THURSDAY
NIGHT. COOL- THE BUT IT TO AND
CAN PHYSICALLY OF THE- AND ALL.
90% ADDITION IT'S POINT THE
MAIN MARC NOW SORT OF- THROUGH
THE INCREASE P. A. YOU THEY DO
WE DO NOT READ PA TO BE ANTI
CERTIFY- TO HAVE LIFE WITHIN K.
BE ON THE AND LICENSE SO THAT
NATIONAL CERTIFICATES IT COULD
FOR NEW VICE INSURED BUT AFTER
THAT PHD NEED TO MAKE THAT EVEN
THOUGH MY PA'S DO. ANSWER THIS
THAT HAVING- I N. ON TO EITHER
MAINTAIN THE NC CAN GET. OR A
CAN TO MEDIC AND CREDITS
OUTSIDE OF THE PROCESS ALLOWS-
NON NATIONALLY CERTIFIED PA'S
TO CONTINUE PRACTICE AND SO
WHAT WE DO IS- WE. AUDIT- THANK
YOU ON I'M HAVING A LOT BIT OF
A I CAN'T REMEMBER THE EXACT
PERCENT OF I WANTED STATES
PERCENT THAT COULD BE MAYBE YOU
COULD COMMENT ON THE PERSON OF
PH THAT WE ARE IT YEAH IT IS
PERCENT OKAY OKAY SO FIVE PER
OF PA'S THAT OUR AUDIT- AND-
YES- TO- TO THE KERR DAY WE
HAVE TO ABOUT SIXTY HUNDRED IN
SEVENTY A LIFE AUDIT. AUDITED
END OF THAT- NINETEEN-
LICENSEES FAILED THE AUDIT SO
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS WE
CONTACT THE LICENSE FEE THAT WE
ASK THEM TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION OF THEIR
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
OR- IF THEY ARE IN TCPA
CERTIFIED REPAIR NCPA CERTIFIED
WE KNOW THAT THEY'VE MET THE-
JAMMY REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE
JUST VERIFY THAT WITH THE NCPA
YES THEY ARE NOT IN TPPA
CERTIFY THEM WILL REQUIRE THEM
TO SUBMIT THEIR- PROOF OF
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
OKAY AND- TO- THAT'S FAR WE'VE
HAD ABOUT ONE POINT ONE THREE
PERCENT- AUDITED LICENSE FEES-
WILL- WHICH IS NINETEEN OF THE
ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE GOT HAVE NOT
FAILED THE ON IT. OKAY I KNOW
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I MEAN THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD PERCENTAGE
AND- THE SENSE OF FAILURE I
GUESS THE AUDIT FAILURE RATE SO
LOW- THAN THAT I THINK THE
PROBABLY PICKS UP WHAT YOU NEED
TO DO THE OTHER QUESTION I
USUALLY ASK BY NO LOOKING AT
YOUR REPORT THAT'S NOT AS MUCH
OF AN ISSUE IS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICIES FOR CONTINUED
EDUCATION HOWEVER I DO KNOW
THAT ALL THE BODIES OF WHAT YOU
REFER TO FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION
DO ALL HAVE CONSERVE INTEREST
POLICIES AS FAR THEIR
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS SO. I
DON'T NINE EIGHT EIGHT YES I
DON'T REALLY NEED. TO ASK A
QUESTION IF YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER PAN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS. OF COMMITTEE CURRENT
IN THE CHAIN AT THIS. CHECK
LATER. THANK THANK YOU CARILLO
A COUPLE QUESTIONS INTERESTED
IN THIS IS ISSUED WAIVER TO DO
WITH THE PANDEMIC. AT THEIR
BEEN ANY PARTICULAR WAIVERS
THAT HAVE BEEN HELPFUL TO- THE
POSITION ASSISTANCE BOARD AND
IT'S NOT LICENSEES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. YES THERE HAVE A
THANK YOU FOR ASKING I
APPRECIATE THAT SO- WE HAVE. RE
WAIVERS THAT ARE IN PLACE RIGHT
NOW- THE FIRST ONE- BASICALLY
HAS TO DO WITH THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND-
THERE RICK YOU KNOW. SUBMIT
THEIR CONTINUING EDUCATION WHEN
THEY RENEW THEIR SENIOR ME.
THAT WHEN THEY RENEW THEIR
LICENSE PLATE- A PROVIDE THAT
DOCUMENTATION UNFORTUNATELY
DURING THE CALL THE PANDEMIC
ESPECIALLY EARLY- IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR SOME LICENSEES
TO. GET THEIR CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION COMPLETED-
OR- SUBMIT THAT SO- THERE IS A
WAIVER THERE. HAS STILL
CURRENTLY IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO- SUBMIT THEIR
DOCUMENTATION OF CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION I'M AFTER THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY- IS
TERMINATED- AND SO THAT IS
GOING TO PLACE A I BELIEVE
SENSE THAT. MAY AND THEN LET
THE PROPOSED THAT IS TO ALLOW A
LICENSE FEES- TO CAN TO PRESS-
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT OF THERE SO DURING
THE COLD RELATED CASH DOWN- BUT
KNOWING THAT IT IS RE. IN THAT
JUST ARGUMENT OF THE AS SOON
THE EMERGENCY LEFT. ANOTHER
WAIVER IS ASKED TO DO ISSUE. SO
HERE HAVE A PRESS AGREE WITH OF
HIS- THAT. SAYS SORT OF WHAT
DUTIES ARE TO BE AND WHAT
THEY'RE TO DO AND A FOR. THAT
OUR SERVICE WITH THAT AGREEMENT.
SOME DURING PANDEMIC- THERE MAY
NOT BE TRYING TO DROP THIS
DOCUMENT AS PEERS ARE CALLED
UPON TO HELP IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS- AND SO- THIS WAIVER
ALLOWS- PH A PRACTICE WITHOUT A
PRACTICE AGREEMENT AS LONG AS
THERE IS AN IDENTIFIED.
SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN AND THEY
HAVE HAD- A FEW OTHER LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS MANTA SO SHADED
WITH THAT. AND THAT WAS A
REALLY IMPORTANT WAY FOR US
OTHERWISE THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE LEGAL DOCUMENTS THAT SIGNED
AND APPROVED IN- WORKED ON
BEFORE A PA COULD REALLY STEP
IN AND HELP OUT IN THE
EMERGENCY SITUATION. THAT WE
WORKED REALLY HARD ON THAT-
WAIVER WITH THAT DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ARE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE. OF THAT HOW HARD
THEY WORK IN THAT MAKING THIS.
HAPPEN SERVICE WE COULD OUT
PA'S COMMANDS FOR EXAMPLE FROM.
OUT OF STATE ACCEPTINGTHEIR
STATE LICENSURE AND- YOU KNOW
ACTING AN OUT OF STATE PRACTICE
AGREEMENT OR WHATEVER THEY'RE
USING IN ANOTHER STATE MAY NOT
HAVE MET SOME OF OUR STATE
REQUIREMENTS BUT THIS WAIVER
ALLOWS THEM TO PRACTICE- I
WITHIN THE STATE WITHOUT
MEETING THAT. AND YOU
REGULATORY BURDENS. THAT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE TO
PRACTICE. WE HAD ANOTHER WAIVER
AS WELL THAT ALLOWS THAT
RETIRED LICENSEES- CHU I
PRACTICED- WITHIN- A TICKET TO
RETURN TO PRESS. LONG THEY'RE
LIKE WAS IN THAT RESTRICTED.
AND THEY WERE LOOKING MAIN IF
YOU'RE OF PRACTICE IT WOULD
TAKE RETURN TO PRACTICE WITHOUT
HAVE TO- PIZZA OF THE- OTHER
REQUIRED OF THE LAW. WOULD HAD
ON THEM- DURING THE TIME OF PAN
AM OF THOSE ARE THE WAIVERS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE. THEY'VE
BEEN RENEWED OF TIMES AND ALL
THESE. ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
TO THE END OF THE- OR JANUARY.
WE THAT IF GIVEN THE RISE IN
THE NUMBER OF COVERED NINETEEN
K. THAT ARE RIGHT- WE EXPECT
THESE WAIVER WILL BE CAN. AND
YOU CAN DO YOU THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW NOBODY KNOWS THE FEW. I WE
THE EXACT BRANCH- EXERCISING
THEIR WISDOM TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN HANDLE THIS PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER TODAY BUT RELATED IT
PIQUES MY INTEREST AS TO
WHETHER. WE SHOULD THROUGH
STATUTORY ACTIONS PREPARE FOR
THESE TYPES OF CONTINGENCIES
RATHER THAN RELYING UPON
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS DURING THE
EMERGENCY I GUESS I'LL- THROW
THAT QUESTION UP IN THE AIR YOU
DON'T NEED TO ANSWER BUT I'LL-
DIRECTED TO MY STAFF AND OTHERS
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER- SUCH ACTIONS- I DO
SEE THAT- YOU KNOW THE
LICENSING PROCESS. HAS BEEN
PRETTY EFFICIENT YOU YOU SAY AT
LEAST IN THIS THE STAFF REPORT.
THIRTY DAYS IS THE AVERAGE TIME
DELAY FOR GETTING A LICENSE IN
MOST CASES THAT RIGHT. THANK
EIGHT BELIEVE THAT TAX- YES
IT'S- NON COMPLICATED LICENSE
IT'S ABOUT THIRTY DAYS IN OTHER
WORDS THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
THAT WOULD RAISE ANY RED FLAGS
DURING THE LICENSING PROCESS.
YEAH CORRECT AND SO WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF APPLICATIONS TO
RAISE FLAGS SAYS NO INDICATION
IT IS IT'S A SMALL PURSES 2%
FIVE PERCENT. OR SOMETHING MORE
SUBSTANTIAL THAT RAIES. ISSUES
THAT WOULD DELAY THE LICENSE
FOR MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS. I
THINK OF OSAMA MIGHT BE ABLE TO
BETTER ANSWER THAT THEN I COULD
ISSUES A LITTLE MORE- A
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS BUT JUST BRIEFLY I IT
WOULD BE THINGS LIKE- IF THEY
HAD SOME SORT OF LICENSURE
BEFORE THEY WERE AN EMT OR
PARAMEDIC OR SOMETHING AND
THAT. LICENSE HAD SOME SORT OF
ACTION ON IT- OR- DALY- WE HAD-
YOU KNOW CRIMINAL INFORMATION
BACKGROUND CHECKS WHERE- THERE
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONCERNING THEIR- OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. ROSANA YEAH THE
PHARMACIST. IS I WOULD SAY IT'S
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ON THE- WILL
BE LEFT ONE PER. OF LICENSEES
THAT- PRIOR OF HISTORY AND WE
TAKES A- LOT LONGER THAN THIRTY
DAY TO PROCESS. AND IT WILL
NEED TRYING. THAT WAS WHAT
CENTER AND ADDS. I'M SORRY IT
WAS ONE PERSON OF MAKING SURE I
COULD HEAR CORRECTLY PERCENT
POINT YEAH I SAY I. A LOT LESS
THAN ONE. OKAY ALL RIGHT YEAH
THAT THAT'S ALL AND TO KNOW AND
THERE'S A IN THAT. THAT THERE
IS SHARE. US IN OUR OURS. BUT
THAT'S THAT THAT'S- IN I
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT
EFFICIENCY AND MAKING SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE. READY FOR THAT
LICENSE CAN CAN GET IT QUICKLY.
AND- I THINK ONE FINAL.
QUESTION- THE YOU KNOW THE
WHOLE. DIVERGENCE HAS- BY
NECESSITY CHANGING THAT THAT
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE- IN
PARTICULAR- THE- YOU KNOW THE
USE OF TELEHEALTH- DO YOU HAVE
ANY ANY ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW OFTEN YOUR PA'S ARE USING
TELEHEALTH SERVICES AND HAVE.
AS MANY ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED
BECAUSE OF THAT. HI I DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION OTHER THAN
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION FROM MY
OWN PERSONAL PRACTICE WHICH IS
THAT YEAH IT'S FAIRLY COMMON-%
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY PROBLEMS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT-
YOU KNOW PA TAPPED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE- PATIENT THAT THEIR-
CARING FOR VIA TELEMEDICINE OR
TELL OF. HEALTH TECHNOLOGY IS
LOCATED WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SO BECAUSE THAT IS
THE AREA WHERE THEY'RE A
LICENSED- YEAH BUT I OTHER THAN
THAT I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY.
PARTICULAR PROBLEMS- IN MY OWN
PERSONAL PRACTICE I'VE ALSO-
MADE IT A POINT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE- PATIENT IS IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN TALK TO ME ABOUT
THEIR HEALTHCARE WITHOUT
CONCERN OF. OTHERS OVER HEARING
AS WELL AS IN A SAFE PLACE AND
HAVE THEM CALL THE FATHER
DRIVING- HELP THEM BE FOR
EXAMPLE IN A RESTAURANT OR A-
YOU KNOW OF. A LARGE AREA WHERE
THEY CAN GET INTERNET ACCESS
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
HEALTHCARE SO SORT OF THOSE
PRIVACY ISSUES THAT WE REMIND
PATIENTS ABOUT- BUT I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY- SIX. SAID BEAR
YOUR- TO TELL THE FOR PH. N.
DASH THEN. A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
WAY YOU SEE A AT THE- AND THEN
YOU TO TELL THAT YOU. THOUGHT
OF- THAT ARE COMING TO THE FORE.
CONVENIENCE EFFICIENCY- COST. I
DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
DEFINITE ADVANTAGES IN TERMS OF
CONVENIENCE FOR THE PATIENT-
FROMA MEDICAL PERSPECTIVE
THERE ARE SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS AND
THAT I CAN'T DO A PHYSICAL
EXAM- AND IT IS OFTEN DIFFICULT
TO GET- LABORATORY ANALYSIS OR
OTHER ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT AIDS IN THE DIAGNOSTICPROCESS- BUT I DO THINK THAT-
PATIENTS- CERTAINLY- MY
EXPERIENCE IS THAT THEY REALLY
LIKE THEY ACCESS THAT'S THERE-
IN AS WELL- YOU KNOW I LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TALK TO MY PATIENTS
AND KIND OF SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THEM IT CAN BE FRUSTRATING
SOMETIMES. BECAUSE OF THAT JUST
THE LIMITATIONS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY WHERE- YOU KNOW
INFORMATION CUTS OUT- DIFFERENT
THINGS LIKE THAT OR SOMETIMES
THEY'LL- GET A TELEHEALTH VISIT
AND THEN HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO
GO ON AND HAVE AN IN PERSON
VISIT AS WE DISCOVER MORE
INTRICATE INFORMATION ON THE
TELE HEALTH BUT I DO THINK
THAT- YEAH CERTAINLY- THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS THAT DEVELOP TO
TELEHEALTH AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO USE IT ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE SET RESTRICTIONS- ON
THE PATIENT'S ABILITY TO
TRAVELER BETWEEN IN PERSON. AND
YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON WHAT
THEY'RE COMPLAINING IS- IT IS
AN APPROPRIATE MEDIUM FOR- FOR
SOME COMPLAINTS AND OTHERS. SAY
THEY REALLY NEED TO BE SEEN IN
PERSON. THANK YOU MUCH THE FOR
THE GOOD WORK THAT THE YOUR
VOICE. AND IT THIS BUT- AREA IF
THERE ARE. PLACES IN WHICH WE
SHOULD- EXAMINE CLOSELY- HOW
TELEHEALTH CAN BE. UTILIZED
AND- WE'RE ALL PATIENT HEALTH
ISSUES ARE. PROPERLY SCENE- ANY
ANY FEEDBACK OR INSIGHT IS
ALWAYS APPRECIATED THERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHECK LATER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CURRENTLY IN THE
CHAMBERS AT THIS TIME. THREE
NINE MOVE ON TO ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE
JOINING US REMOTELY. NOW'S THE
TIME IF YOU A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WHICH IS TO ASK. ANY
QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE ANY
COMMENTS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO DO
SO AT THIS TIME AN INMATE
YOURSELF AND PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. K.
HEARING NO QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME FOR MY HAT WELL. SHARE
YES- YEAH I HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS YES WE WOULD UKIAH
KILEY IDENT. IDENTIFY YOURSELF
CAN YOU BACK HERE WHEN HELLO IN
THE MORNING WORK. YES HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT THE- WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE ISSUES OF HOW TO OUR
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS FOR
PA'S- COMPARED TO OTHER STATES.
THAT'S A THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- I'VE ACTUALLY I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T WASN'T ABLE TO-
HERE. TO WHOM THE QUESTION WAS
FROM. THE QUESTION IS FROM
ASSEMBLYWOMAN JACQUI IRWIN.
OKAY THANK YOU- MR WELL I AM
LICENSED IN OR PRE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY LICENSED IN THREE
STATES SO I CAN CERTAINLY CAN-
COMPARED TO THOSE- BUT YEAH
GENERALLY SPEAKING- ARE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS- ARE
SIMILAR TO MOST STATES- IN THAT
WE REQUIRE A FAIRLY EXTENSIVE-
BACKGROUND CHECK- CRIMINAL
INFORMATION CHECK WE VERIFIED
THAT- THAT THE APPLICANT HAS
NOT GOT ANY- ADVERSE. ACTIONS
ON THEIR- LICENSE IF THEY'RE
COMING FROM ANOTHER STATE-
MAKING SURE THAT THEY AFFECT
HAD- MEDICAL MALPRACTICE THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE- THE
DETAILS ON THAT- AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT THEY- YOU KNOW ME
TO ALL THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
PRESCRIBED IN OUR VARIOUS
REGULATIONS- HAVING THEM
LICENSED IN BOTH NEVADA AND
WASHINGTON- I CAN SAY THAT. OUR
PROCESS AND- REQUIREMENTS ARE
VERY SIMILAR TO THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON- AND SOMEWHAT SOON
ABOUT A- WHICH OF WAS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT IN THAT DAY- AT
THE TIME I WAS LICENSE ARE
REQUIRED. PERSONAL APPEARANCE
BEFORE THE BOARD TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE WHICH WE DO NOT
REQUIRE- THAT I THINK I EVER
WENT TO- LAST YEAR AND MEETING
AT THE FEDERATION OF STATE
MEDICAL BOARDS WAS ABLE TO TALK
TO- MY COLLEAGUES FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY. AND MOST OF OUR
PROCESSES AND PRACTICES ARE
QUITE. SIMILAR TO OTHER STATES.
ARIZONA WE YOU HAVE ANY TO ADD
THEIR- AND NOW YOU THAT. YOU
SAID PRETTY WELL BEING YOU. AND
THEN I HAD- OTHER THAT OF YOU
KNOW IT'S AND OF A AUNT CONCERN.
AND US IN THE AND THAT'S A-
GETTING CARE PROFESSIONALS TO
INTO UNDERSERVED AREAS WHAT IS
BEING DONE OR WHAT MORE CAN BE
DONE TO ATTRACT PA'S TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS IN CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION AS A
YOU KNOW I GREW UP IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND- WHO LIVED
THERE FOR QUITE SOME TIME- AND
THERE IS A YOU KNOW SORT OF
HAVE WE UNDERSERVED AREA THERE
I APPRECIATE THE- EMPHASIS ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET
PROVIDERS TO WHERE THEY'RE
NEEDED. MOST IN THOSE
UNDERSERVED AREAS- THE PA BOARD
SAID JOB REALLY IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT- AT PJ'S ARE PRACTISING
SAFELY WHEREVER THEY'RE SAYING-
CONSUMERS WHETHER. CHEN AND
UNDERSERVED AREA OR NOT. MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA- TRY TO RECRUIT AND
EMPLOYEE SAID APPEARING THEN
THOSE UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
THERE ARE MANY- PROGRAMS FOR PA
IF THEY GO TO THOSE AREAS TO
OBTAIN. A LOAN REPAYMENT AND
THAT SORT OF THING BY US SO WE
CERTAINLY TRACK. BEAT THE PLAYA
P. EIGHTEEN- WE DON'T- THE
PEOPLE DOES NOT TRACK THE
DISTRIBUTION OF WHERE THEIR-
PRACTICING- THAT THERE ARE
OTHER AS STATE AGENCIES THAT DO
THAT WE ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT IN PARTICULAR-
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY PROCESSES
THAT WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
PRACTICE. IN RURAL AREAS AND IN
FACT THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
BENEFITS- SB SIX NINETY SEVEN
IS THAT IT DOES ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR APPEARS TO BE
PRACTICING. AND SOME OF THOSE
RURAL AREAS REMOVED SOME OF THE
MORE ONEROUS THAT SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT PH COULD
PRACTICE- SAFELY IN THOSE AREAS
AND PROVIDE. INCREASED ACCESS
TO CARE. RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN
MIGHT THERE BE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FOR MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. OKAY
YOU'RE HERE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WHO WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. SIGNAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CURRENTLY IN THE
CHAMBERS TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE MY WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE WHO WISH TO SPEAK. SHARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO. LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE ONE I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO FOR
ANY COMMENT. AND ONE MORE TIME-
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW IT'LL BE JUST
A MOMENT FOR THAT ONE LINE.
LOCAL TIME FOURTEEN PLEASE I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
THE NUMBERS MY NAME'S AT HOWARD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR PH I'M JUST A
FEW COMMENTS VERY BRIEFLY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON- FIRST WE DO WANT TO
THANK PRESIDENT GRANT AND THE
PHD STAFF FOR AGREEING TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH- KAPPA-
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SENATOR COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE IMPORTANT
IMPLEMENTATION. OF SB SIX
NINETY SEVEN- WE DO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS A BY THE P.
A. B. TO THAT BILL- THAT WERE
PROPOSED AS A PART OF THEIR
SUNSET REVIEW REPORT FOR THE
REASONS LAID OUT IN OUR LETTER-
IN BECAUSE THOSE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WERE THEMSELVES
OPPOSED LAST YEAR BY CAP- THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SENATOR CAFIERO- THE FINAL
THING IS I WANTED TO TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IRWIN QUESTION BACK UNDERSERVED
AREAS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT WHY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT IN A KAPPA
IS ATTEMPTING TO MIRROR THE I
BELIEVE IT'S THE STEVEN
THOMPSON. OF FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD I'M
OFFERING A LOAN REPAYMENT AND
RELIEF TO THOSE WHO WORK IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND PERHAPS
ATTEMPTING TO MIRROR SUCH A
PROPOSAL UP FOR P. AGE- AT THE
PRESIDENT GRANT- VERY A QUITE
CORRECTLY SAID THAT EXECUTIVE
WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARD. I'M
OFFERING THE KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY THAT AT THAT WOULD
ENHANCE- THE SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE THEIR AND THEN- IN SOME-
AND THINKING YOU'RE GOING TO
STAY OUT A REALLY TERRIFIC-
BACKGROUND PAPER WE- ACCOUNTING
SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OF THE
BORTON PLEASE CANCEL ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I MY WE HAVE IN
AT THE MEMBERS. OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE PHONE
AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY ANY OF THE FINAL
THOUGHTS ARE CLOSING- COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY AT AT THIS TIME
FOR MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. K. IF THE NUN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TO THE WORKING
AND HELPING TO IDENTIFY A
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES AND WE
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR ON THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THEIR MUCH RADICALS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. CALLS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE REVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. AND
UNDERSTAND THAT- THAT THE NEXT
OUT. WITNESSES B. ALSO JOINING
US THROUGH VIDEO CONFERENCE AS
WELL. AGAIN THIS IS NOW ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. AND
WILL BE JOINED BY A FEW OF OUR
COMMISSIONERS. A FIRST OFF WE
ARE JOINED BY DOUG MCAULEY
SECONDS BY SANDRA. NOW AND
THIRDLY BY STEPHEN LERNER
ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER FOR
LEGAL AFFAIRS. THE
COMMISSIONERS FEEL PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN WELCOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I LIKE TO
THINK SHARES MY NAME IS DOUG
MCCAULEY I'M REAL STATE
COMMISSIONER I'VE BEEN SORT OF
SERVING IN THIS ROLE SINCE MAY
OF THIS YEAR. AND IS YOU
INDICATED WITH ME IS STEVEN
LEARNER WHO'S OUR SYSTEM
COMMISSIONER FOR LEGAL AFFAIRS
AND SANDRA NOW WHO'S OUR
ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND LICENSING.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO COMMEND
COMMITTEE STAFF WE KNOW THE
HARD WORK INVOLVES TO GET
THROUGH OUR EXTENSIVE REPORTING
THE METRICS AND IDENTIFY GOOD
ISSUES TO BRING FORTH A
FRUITFUL CONVERSATION FOR US
TODAY SO WE CAN COLLABORATE- SO
WE'RE PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO
HAVE THE COOPERATIVE APPROACH
THAT WE ENJOYED. DURING THIS
PROCESS. AND SO WHAT I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSCORE SOME OF THE
OPERATIONAL COMPONENTS- DIARI
AND THEN TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
ECONOMIC. REALITIES AND WE WILL
STATE FROM THERE I'LL TALK
ABOUT WHY WE ACTUALLY REGULATE
THE PROFESSION AND WHAT OUR
APPROACH IS TO DO SO- AND THEN
LASTLY THERE'S A KEY POLICY
ISSUE I'D LIKE TO IDENTIFY THAT
I KNOW IS CLOSE TO SOME OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES. SO
FIRST WITH RESPECT TO DRV UR
MISSION IS TO BE. TO SAFEGUARD
AND PROMOTE THE PUBLIC INTEREST
OF REAL ESTATE THROUGH
REGULATION LICENSING
EXAMINATION AND EDUCATION AND
OUR VISION IS TO BE THE
CHAMPIONS OF PUBLIC PROTECTION
IN REAL ESTATE. AND WE'RE VERY
CLEAR THAT THAT SAME CONCEPT IS
EMBEDDED IN OUR STATUTE BROADEN
CENTER THE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
IS PRIORITY ONE WITH RESPECT TO
THE SCOPE OF OUR UNIVERSE WE
HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
LICENSEES WHICH IS COMPRISED OF
TWO HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
SALESPERSONS ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND BROKERS. AND TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND MORTGAGE LOAN
ORIGINATORS WE ALSO A REVIEW
AND APPROVE SUBDIVISIONS AND
LAST FISCAL YEAR WE APPROVE
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED PUBLIC.
REPORTS WHICH EQUATES. TO
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND UNITS OF
NEW HOUSING. TO DRIVE THIS WE
HAVE THREE HOW AND SIXTEEN
STAFF MEMBERS OF DIARI HOW
DIDN'T. FIVE DID OFFICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA EACH OF
WHICH EXAM. ASSOCIATED WITH.
OUR BUDGET TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. OVER THE LAST YEARS
WE'VE ARE HARD TO RE CONCERT
OURSELVES AS A- WE WERE. A
BUREAU THE OF. AFFAIRS AND I'M-
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE OR DOES
THAT ALL OF THE COME. OF THAT
BUILD OUT ARE NOW AND WE'RE
FULLY FUNCTION AS A DEPARTMENT.
SO NOW BIT ABOUT THE ECHO
FOOTPRINT OF REALISTIC IT'S A
REAL ESTATE IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR BILLION. OF OUR GROSS
PRODUCT APPROXIMATE TWENTY
PERCENT. AND THEN EACH
INDIVIDUAL TRANSACTION.
GENERATES A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND OF ECONOMIC POSITIVE
AND IMPACT IN THE LOCAL MARKET.
LOOKING FORWARD TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE ARE LOOKING FOR A
MODEST INCREASE IN EXISTING
HOME SALES. OF APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT THREE PERCENT. AND
IN TERMS OF THE MEDIAN HOME
PRICE WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT THREE AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THESE
NUMBERS ARE COURTESY OF THE
CALIFORNIA REALTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. SO WITH RESPECT TO
WHY WE REGULATE REAL ESTATE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE NATURE
OF THESE TRANSACTIONS FOR YOUR
AVERAGE AN ORDINARY CONSUMER.
IT'S GOING TO BE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT THEY MAKE IN THEIR
LIFE. AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT THOSE TRANSACTIONS REQUIRE
WE'RE TALKING LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF STATUTES AND
OBLIGATIONS THAT HAVE TO BE
EFFECTUATED PROPERLY. TO ENSURE
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND THEN
LASTLY AGAIN I REFER YOU BACK
TO THE ECONOMIC FOOTPRINT
BECAUSE OF THEM BACK INTO A
WHAT REAL ESTATE. INVOLVED
FINANCIALLY IN CALIFORNIA YOU
DO HAVE A TENDENCY TO SEE ABOUT
ACTORS TRYING TO ENTER THE
MARKET PLACE. AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CONSUMERS. SO WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR US IN TERMS OF
OUR PHILOSOPHY IS WE WORK HARD
TO BE VERY PREVENTIVE WITH OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS IT'S- MUCH
MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO BE
PREVENTIVE RATHER THAN PROMEDIO
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION. IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE AND IT'S VERY TIME
CONSUMING TO PROSECUTE CASES.
WE CAN BE MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE
BY. GETTING OUT THERE THE
QUITTING THE PROFESSION WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO
OPERATE WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
REAL ESTATE LAW. AND ALSO
EDUCATE CONSUMERS SO THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR GUARD UP AND BE
PREPARED TO HAVE SUCCESSFUL
TRANSACTIONS. AND WE'RE WORKING
TO ENHANCE OUR EFFORTS IN THIS
REGARD WERE ACTUALLY FURTHER
BUILDING OUT OF COMMUNICATIONS
AND PUBLICATIONS OPERATION SO
WE CAN DO MORE. AND USE
DIFFERENT MODALITY IS FOR A NEW
CATIONS AND EDUCATION I'M
PERSONALLY VERY FIRMLY
COMMITTED TO THIS DURING MY
SHORT TENURE I'VE ALREADY
PRESENTED TO FORTY DIFFERENT
LOCAL ASSOCIATIONS OF REALTORS
AND IT'S- IN A TREMENDOUS. WAY
TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON VARIOUS LOCAL MARKETS. AND
WHAT THEIR CHALLENGES ARE. SO
AGAIN WE'RE BACK THE MAGNITUDE
OF THIS PROFESSION ECONOMIC
IMPACT IT DOES IN FACT TEND TO
DRAW SOME OF THOSE BAD APPLES
INTO THE MARKETPLACE-
UNLICENSED PRACTICE IS A-
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
US AND ONE OF THE POINTS OF
EMPHASIS FOR ME COMING AND- IS
LEVERAGING OUR CITATION
PROGRAM. PREVIOUSLY THAT
APARTMENT TO ROCK RELIED
PRIMARILY ON THE SYSTEM REFRAIN
ORDERS BUT I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO. BE AS
IMPACTFUL AS YOU CAN WITH THESE
ACTIONS IN THE FINANCIAL
PENALTY. CERTAINLY ACCOMPLISHES
ABOUT SO WE WANT A STRONG
DETERRENT IN THE MARKETPLACE
AND WE ARE. GOING TO RAMP UP
OUR USE OF THE CITATION.
AUTHORITY ANIMAL WAITED LOWER
US CLEANER EFFORTS TO POLICE
THE MARKET. AND THIS PROBLEM SO
WE'RE INCREASING OUR
ACTIVITIES- THE OTHER VARIOUS
ONLINE PRESENCES TO MONITOR AND
IDENTIFY THESE BAD ACTORS IN
THE MARKETPLACE. IN ADDITION
WE'RE CONNECTING WITH THE LOCAL
ASSOCIATIONS BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND THERE
ARE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
OF THEM AND- UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
OF US SO WE DEFINITELY RELY ON
THEM TO SHARE WITH US. WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE MARKET PLACE
AND WE APPRECIATE. THAT
COLLABORATION. AND THEN LASTLY
WE'RE LEVERAGING OUR
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT SO WE CAN
ALSO USE THOSE TO TRIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO STEP
IN. IN THE MARKETPLACE. FOR ME.
SO THE OTHER HALF OF A BACK
CONSUMER PROTECTION USED EAM.
THAT'S GONNA WHETHER FOLKS
COMING INTO THE MARKET PLACE.
HAVE THE REQUISITE KNOWLEDGE
SKILLS AND ABILITIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IN A SAFE AND
REASONABLE WAY FOR CONSUMERS.
SO WE REALLY REALLY VALUE THE
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
THE REAL RELY UPON TO. CRAFT
THE CONTENT FOR THE EXAM IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE'RE
TESTING PER WHAT'S GOING ON IN.
TODAY'S MARKET PLACE BUT WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO EXPAND ACCESS TO THE
EXAM.SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
OUT VIA NEW TECHNOLOGY OR
PERHAPS OTHER PRESENCES IN
CALIFORNIA. TO OFFER THE EXAM.
ON THE POLICY SIDE I DEFINITELY
WATER PRIVATE PUT A BRIGHT
LIGHT ON THIS BECAUSE I KNOW SO
MANY OF YOU. HAVE YOUR HANDS ON
THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR BUT
SHORTLY AFTER I LANDED A D. R.
READ WE TOOK ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY. OF UPDATING THE
KIND OF GUY WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY PART OF PUBLISHED
BY. THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO AND
IT WAS IN. DIRE NEED OF AN
UPDATE WHICH WE DID AND WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THAT WORK WE USE
A VERY INCLUSIVE PROCESS TO
RECEIVE STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
AND ENSURE THAT WE PRODUCED A
QUALITY. AND BALANCED DOCUMENT
BUT- WITH OUR CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH CLIMATE AND ALL THE
AFFECTS OF COVERT PARTICULAR ON
UNEMPLOYMENT REDUCED WAGES. AND
HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSECURITY. IT WAS QUICKLY
NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIA STEP
UP AND TAKE SOME APPROPRIATE
ACTION TO CREATE SOME NEW
PROTECTIONS. SO ASSEMBLY MEN'S
TO CHOOSE SOME OF THE AUTHORITY
EIGHTY EIGHT WAS SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM ON.
AUGUST THE THIRTY FIRST AS AN
EMERGENCY MEASURE AND IT HAD
SOME CRITICAL PROTECTIONS THAT
NEEDED. TO BE IMPLEMENTED INTO
ORDER SO THAT TENANTS COULD
TAKE ADVANTAGE AND LANDLORDS
WOULD UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS
AND PRIVILEGES AND SO. WHILE
THE INK WAS STILL WET ON THE
BILL WE WERE CRAFTING THE
REQUIRED DECLARATIONS IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES TO POST THEM
ON THE WEBSITE AND- THE
GOVERNOR'S CAMPAIGN IN THE
SPACES CALL HOUSING IS KEY AND
THE WEBSITE IS HOUSING IS KEY
DOT COM SO. THE WEBSITE HOUSES
THOSE REQUIRE DECLARATIONS
ALONG WITH OTHER SUPPORT
MATERIAL. FAQS FACT SHEETS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY RESOURCES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE OFTEN.
IN THESE SCENARIOS LEGAL
REPRESENTATION IT IS NEEDED
ALMOST ALWAYS SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THAT
DIRECTION DOWN TO LOCAL
RESOURCES. BUT AS YOU WELL KNOW
AS LAWMAKERS IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DISTILL DOWN
LEGISLATIVE INFORMATION SO THE
GRASS ROOTS LEVEL. IN SHORT
ORDER SO WE TOOK A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL STEPS SO FIRST
PARTNERING WITH OUR FRIENDS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. WE
COLLABORATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
LAW SCHOOL. AND A TECH COMPANY
ON THE EAST COAST CALL ME OUT
SO. LARGE AND WE CRAFTED IN.
OUT WHICH WOULD ACT WALK THE
USE THROUGH THE VERY FAST OF
THE LAW. BASE UPON THE FACT. SO
THEY CAN BETTER. PROTECTION
THEY ENJOY. UNDER THE LOS. IF
THE BANK OF THAT. I'M HEARING
FEEDBACK. MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
STILL HEAR ME YES WE CAN THANK
YOU. I THOUGHT I LOST YOU FOR A
MOMENT SO- WITH RESPECT TO THE
APP IN THE COLLABORATION WITH
UC IRVINE OF A TECH COMPANY ALL
THE SUPPORT SERVICES FROM THOSE
THIRD PARTIES WERE PROVIDED PRO
BONO SO WE'RE VERYPROUDOF
THAT WORK. ADDITIONALLY WE
WANTED TO FIND OTHER MEANS TO
CONNECT THIS INFORMATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND SO WE PARTNERED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WERE ABLE
TO EMBED LANDLORD TENANT
INFORMATION ON THE STATEWIDE
TWO ONE ONE SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY AND SOME OF YOU
MAY HAVE NOTICED WHEN YOUR YOUR
HOME THE DISTRICTS ARE WE ALSO
UPDATED THE LEGISLATURE'S
LANDLORD TENANT. SO WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THIS WORK. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS TO EXPIRE AT THE
END OF JANUARY SO- THERE'S
GOING TO BE AN ADDITIONAL LEFT
FORTHCOMING TO. FIND OTHER
MEANS TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS
HOUSE. AND SO WITHOUT ON THE
COINCIDE FOR US LIKE ALL
DEPARTMENTS BOARDS AND BUREAUS
THERE WAS A DIRECT EFFECT
OPERATIONALLY ON US. SO WE WERE
CLOSED DOWN TO THE PUBLIC FOR A
SHORT WHILE BUT- I'M PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT WE HAVE 87% OF
OUR STAFF. ON THE TELEWORK
SCHEDULE. ADDITIONALLY THE
MOST- VISIBLE COMPONENT OF THE
IMPACTS TO OUR CONSUMERS WAS OF
COURSE THE EXAM CENTER BECAUSE
IT WAS SHUT DOWN FOR A WHILE.
AND ONCE WE ACQUIRED ALL THE
REQUISITE EQUIPMENT PLEXI GLASS
SHATTERING- WE ARE OPERATING AT
50% CAPACITY BUT I AM VERY
PROUD OF OUR STAFF AND THE
SPACE BECAUSE- THROUGH DILIGENT
SCHEDULING AGGRESSIVELY
CONTACTING OUR APPLICANTS TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE GONNA.
EARLY COMMITTED OUR TIME WE'VE
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERED MORE
EXAMS THAN WE DID THIS TIME
LAST YEAR. SO AGAIN WE'RE
THRILLED TO BE BUILT OUT AS THE
DEPARTMENT ONCE AGAIN I'M
REALLY EXCITED BECAUSE THERE'S
A NEW COMMISSIONER- FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN YEARS WE HAVE A
FULL COMPLEMENT OF EXECUTIVES
ON OUR TEAM TWO OF WHICH ARE
ON- THIS WEBCAST WITH ME TODAY
SO WE'RE VERY WELL POSITIONED
TO CONTINUE OUR EXCELLENT
CONSUMER PROTECTION WORK. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO
FIRM FURTHER OUR CONSUMER
PROTECTION EFFORTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COMMISSIONER MACAULEY
OF WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR. YOUR
SERVICE AND YOUR TEAM AS WELL.
AND ONE L. OFFER OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND
WILL BEGIN WITH ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CURRENTLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS AT THIS TIME
WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE LIKE TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME. YOUR GLAZER. THANK YOU
CHAIR LOW- AND THANK YOU FOR
THE REPORT- AND FOR WORKING
WITH OUR STAFFS ON A FEW OF THE
ISSUES THAT REMAIN FROM OUR
SUNSET FROM BEFORE AND WE HAVE
HERE. STILL IN PLAY- JUST A
COUPLE SMALL QUESTIONS THAT
DOES YOUR DEPARTMENT OFFER
EXAMINATIONS IN- AND OTHER
LANGUAGES. WE DO NOT AT THIS
TIME. AND WHY IS THAT. LARGELY-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE
HAVE A ROVISION OF THE LAW
THAT REQUIRES COMPETENCY IN
ENGLISH AS A FUNCTION OF
BECOMING LICENSED VASTLY THE
EXAM IS OFFERED ONLY IN ENGLISH
AT THIS TIME. WELL I APPRECIATE
THAT THE VALUE AND KNOWING
ENGLISH I'M JUST WONDERING
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S-
RESPONSIVE TO THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- DOESN'T REQUIRE
SOMEONE TO KNOW ENGLISH TO
PURCHASE A HOME IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT IS CORRECT AND SO WHY
WOULD WE NOT. MAKE EVERY EFFORT
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE- HAD A REPRESENT
THAT SAME DIVERSITY OF CULTURE
AND LANGUAGE. THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
A FAIR QUESTION- CENTER WERE
HAPPY TO LOOK INTO IT AND
IDENTIFY THE METRICS THAT WE BE
NEEDING TO HAVE TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON THIS BUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
GIVEN THE- DIVERSITY IN CHAPTER
OF CALIFORNIANS IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE BE MINDFUL OF THIS
AND THAT OUR PROGRAMS REFLECTED-
YOU KNOW- WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
THE- INCOME INEQUALITY BUT- FOR
THOSE WHO TO GIVE A KID A
CAREFUL EXAMINATION. YOU KNOW
YOU REALLY SEE- PROBLEM OF
ASSET INEQUALITY. AND WE KNOW
THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP IS ONE OF
THOSE KEY AREAS- AND ABILITY
TO- PROVIDE ECONOMIC STABILITY-
FOR THE PRESIDENT THE FUTURE-
AND THAT. YOU KNOW THERE THERE
IS SOME WORRY OUT THERE AND I
GUESS IT'S ADDRESSED IN THE
STAFF REPORT ON WHAT ABOUT-
DUAL REPRESENTATION YOU KNOW
THE INSIDER DEALS. WERE ONLY
THE INSIDERS GET TO KNOW ABOUT
HOMES THAT MAY BE FOR SALE. IT
REALLY THREATEN ME UP CORD
ABOUT HOW CAREFUL WE HAVE TO BE
TO ENSURE. NOT JUST IN THE
AREA- IN YOUR DEPARTMENTS-
SPACE BUT IN ALL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT THAT WE- WE MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED THAT THAT THAT WE
GIVE THEM A- HELPING HAND TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ALL THE-
OPPORTUNITIES- TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AND TO ACQUIRE REAL ESTATE IN.
AND LIVE GREAT LIVES SO- THIS
IS A PLACE OF SOME SENSITIVITY
TO ME AND I KNOW TO OTHERS AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR EXAMINATION
ATTENTION TO THAT AND CERTAINLY
THE ISSUE OF LANGUAGE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE- IT CAN BE A HUGE
BARRIER THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUY SOME
PROPERTY IN ANOTHER COUNTRY YOU
DON'T SPEAK THE LANGUAGE BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO YOU AND YOU
KNOW THE VALUE OF IT. WHY YOU
WOULD WANT TO HAVE SOME WHITE
WHY WOULD WE NOT DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO. MAKE IT AS EASY AS
WE CAN FOR PEOPLE AND- WE WOULD
IF WE KNOW THIS ISSUE IN TERMS
OF VOTING. AND THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE MAKE ON COUNTIES
PROVIDE. VOTING PAFFORD SAID
LOTS OF LANGUAGES AND SO- I
NOTICE COMES A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF THE BLUE MISTER CHAIRMAN
BUT- I'M GLAD WE HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OF
HELP WE CAN EXAMINE IT FURTHER.
VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHECK
LATER AND SOMEBODY TO THAT
POINT TO ECHOED THAT. SAME
SENTIMENT TO THIS IS THE
PURPOSE OF. THESE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
DIALOGUE IN THE TRANSPARENT
FASHION ABOUT OUTLINING. ISSUES
THAT WE'VE. THAT HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION AND TO
ALLOW FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON MANY OF THOSE ISSUES
SO- PLEASE TO INTERPRET THOSE-
I WOULD EQUALLY INTERPRETERS
COMES TO SAY THAT THERE IS A-
THE SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT WE ARE SERVING
OUR PUBLIC AND OUR COMMUNITY.
AND REPRESENTING THE STRENGTH
OF OUR DIVERSITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE GLAZER ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS NOW FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT ARE DIALING IN.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WHO ARE NOW DIALING IN OR ON
VIDEO CONFERENCE WISHING TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME OR
PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS. IT WILL
OPEN UP THE LINE PLEASE. I AND
ANY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
FEEL FREE TO CHIME IN WHENEVER
YOU FEEL READY. OKAY AGAIN ALL
OF OUR FINAL CALL FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TEST QUESTION
OR PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS. CASEY
C. NONE BEEN- OF. COMMISSIONER
THE ISSUE A NUMBER TWO AS YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE DIALOGUE
WITH YOU WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRANSITION FROM BUREAU TO
DEPARTMENT. A STATUS COULD YOU
GIVE US SOME INSIGHTS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY. WITH VARIOUS
OTHER AGENCIES AND ENTITIES.
AND I THINK. WITH OUR CALVET
AGENCY THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY AND
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP. WITH AGENCY WE
HAVE A MONTHLY READING SESSION
WITH SECRETARY CASTRO
MERITORIOUS DOWN A FIRE OR
ISSUES. RESOURCE ISSUES
IMPEDIMENTS NEW INITIATIVES
THAT SANDRA AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A MONTHLY DIRECTORS CALL
WERE ALL OF THE DIRECTORS SLASH
COMMISSIONERS ARE ON AND- WE
CAN FIND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLABORATION WERE BRIEFED ON
KEY ADMINISTRATION A MISSION-
SO WE CAN IDENTIFY STRATEGIES
SO WITH THOSE TWO PIECES WE
HAVE A VERY. STRONG
RELATIONSHIP I HAVE FREQUENT
REGULAR COMMUNICATION. WITH THE
POLICY LEAVE THE GOVERNOR
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR HOUSING
AND CONSUMER SERVICES OVER
THERE- WE DO COLLABORATE
STRONGLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF. FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
AS WELL AS THE NEW DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION. AND
INNOVATION DOCTORS ON PHONE
LAST NIGHT WITH MIKE
COMMISSIONER THEIR OWN.
IMPORTANT DISPLAY CASE YES SO
WE DO ANGELES STRONG- ADDITION
WE HOW THOSE AT THE LOW LEVEL
VIA VARIOUS LOGGING FOR FORMS
TASK FORCES- WITH SHERIFF THE-
DISTRICT. AND SUMMER IN DRUG
BACK- YEAH WE DEFINITELY
PRESENCE THIS WITH YOUR PRO
STAY GROUPS AND THE STATE LAW
ONE OF. PIECES ON THE WAS WE
FEEL THAT WE HAVE AND THE PANDA.
AND MILES WOULD BE YES WE HAVE
SO DO WE HAVE PER SHAKING THE
APART WITH CABINET. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IF I AM A
LICENSE. WHAT TYPE OF IN. WE I
SEE. OR WHAT HAVE IMPACT I FEEL.
OF RESPECT TO THE- TO THE
CHANGE. ANY ONE. DEPARTMENTAL
USE NOT ANY- ENFORCEMENT
PROCESSES ARE THE SAME SO IF
YOU'RE ON THAT SIDE OF THE
EQUATION UNFORTUNATELY-
LICENSING SYSTEMS ARE THE SAME
ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS I'D
CONVEY MISTER CHAIRMAN IS ONE
OF THE PIECES THAT DIDN'T
CONVERT OVER TO. I WOULD
CONSUMER AFFAIRS WAS OUR IT
SHOP SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MAINTAIN SOME CONSISTENCY ABOUT
ROME AND THEREFORE. OUR ONLINE
FUNCTIONALITY E. LICENSING ALL
THEIR VARIOUS TRANSACTIONS THAT
YOU CAN PERFORM THAT SPACE BUT
REMAIN THE SAME THROUGHOUT THE
TRANSITION. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THOSE ARE ALL THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE AT THIS TIME
WHEN I MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. MIGHT THERE BE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK CURRENTLY IN THE CHAMBERS
AT THIS TIME. SEE THAT THERE
ARE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE CHAMBERS AT THE- OR DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ON THE PHONE. WHO WISH TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME. WE NEED TO HAVE
ONE AND AS A REMINDER IT LONDON
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
LONDON FERAL. LOCAL TO LINE
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER WELL I'M IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT PRESS LONDON THEY'RE
ALL JUST ONE TIME. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANKS FOR- HI ADRIN MOHAMMED
WITH A CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION- I THOUGHT I WOULD
BE Q. EARLIER OR THE PHYSICIAN
IN CERTAIN PORTS- FORGIVE ME-
BUT JUST VERY QUICKLY I WANT TO
LET YOU AND THE COMMITTEE NO
THAT- WE ARE WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS OF KAPPA
EARLIER AND- WE CAN PIECE AND-
THAT WERE IN CONFLICT WITH THE
B. CABIN AIR A BILL THAT WE
HAVE WORKED ON WITH- KAPPA AND
THE SENATOR LAST YEAR- THAT WE
SUPPORTED WE BERMAN SPORTED AN
ASPECT YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT. CHANGES TO THE
AGREEMENT THAT WERE MADE DURING
THE NEGOTIATIONS- TO THE
CONDITIONS THAT THE BOARD SO
WITH THAT IT'S ONE TO LET YOU
ALL KNOW AND. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME. NEED TO HAVE ONE
MORE IN THE QUEUE ON THAT WITH
THE LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN IF I
HAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN THANK YOU
YES YEAH. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON ANNA BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OUR ORGANIZATION HAVE
MEMBERS WHICH IS IN THE RANGE
OF ABOUT 40% OF THE REAL ESTATE
LICENSEE POPULATION AND IN THE
STATE WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER. IN LIGHT
OF THE DEMANDS MADE ON THE
DEPARTMENT REAL ESTATE IN THE
STAFFING ISSUES IDENTIFIED IN
THE BRIEFING PAPER ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC C. A. R. IS
VERY SENSITIVE TO THE NEED FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO STAY CLOSE TO
ITS CORE MISSION OF.
SAFEGUARDING AND PROMOTING THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN REAL ESTATE
MATTER THROUGH LIKE YOUR
REGULATION EDUCATION AND
ENFORCEMENT ENSURING THAT THE
LICENSING PROCESS IS PROPERLY
AND FAIRLY ADMINISTERED AND
THAT LIFE EITHER PROPERLY
REGULATED IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
INTERESTS OF BOTH THE INDUSTRY
AND THE PUBLIC- WE HAVE HAD
ONGOING CONCERNS IN THE PAST
ABOUT THE CONSISTENCY. OF THE
APPLICATION OF THE ARE YOU
DISCIPLINE AND THE TREATMENT OF
VIOLATIONS BY AUDITORS HOWEVER
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A RECENT CHANGE IN
LEADERSHIP AT THE DEPARTMENT I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MAY BE
CHANGES IN THESE AREAS BUT WE
ONCE AGAIN WANT TO URGE THE
DEPARTMENT TO CAREFULLY REVIEW
THEIR ENFORCEMENT APPROACH SO
THAT SIMILARLY SITUATED LIKE
THESE. ARE TREATED SIMILARLY.
TO BE CLEAR AREN'T EIGHT IS IN
OF BIGGER IMPORTANT OF THE LAW
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. OUR
MEMBERS ARE THE MOST AFFECTED
BY THAT ACCURATE THAT- CAN
EMERGE ESPECIALLY DURING TRYING
TIMES SUCH AS THESE. THE NEED
TO MAINTAIN FOCUS ON THE CORE
MISSION HOWEVER SPEAKS AGAIN.
OUR MISSION CREEP OR THE
ASSUMPTION OF NUDITY NEW
DUTIES. SOME OF WHICH- ARE
BROUGHT UP IN IN THE BRIEFING
PAPER TODAY AS AS THE
COMMISSIONER MENTIONED THE
PURCHASE OF A HOME. IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FINANCIAL PURCHASE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
EVER MAKE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT THEY COMMISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO BE THE
FOCUS- WITH REGARD TO SOME OF
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES RAISED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF. I DO HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS. FIRST WE BELIEVE
THAT THE ISSUE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND YOU'LL AGENCIES
AND- ADDRESSED A DETAILED
AGENCY DISCLOSURE FORM THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN STATUTE-
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES
PURPOSES. THE COMMITTEE REPORT
REPRESENTS EIGHTY TEN FIFTY
NINE AS A BILL TO BARRED YOU'LL
AGENCY BUT IN FACT THE FOR THE
BILL TO BAR YOU'LL AGENCY
SOLELY IN THE COMMERCIAL ARENA.
THE COMMITTEE ALSO IDENTIFIES
THE RECENT AND LIKELY ONGOING
LEGISLATION IN. B. AT HOUSING
AND LANDLORD TENANT ARENA- I'D
LIKE TO STATE THAT WE BELIEVE
ONCE AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT CORE
MISSION HERE SHOULD BE TO MAKE
SURE LICENSE FEES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE AND WHERE RELEVANT
EDUCATED ON THESE ISSUES.
HOWEVER WE DO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT MISSION CREEP
AND THIS AND OTHER AREAS. THAT
THE COMMITTEE BRINGS UP AND WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT. GIVEN THE
LIMITED RESOURCES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD BE THE CONDUIT FOR
PROVIDING INFORMATION ON THESE
ISSUES EXCEPT. IN SO FAR AS-
FORMED- VERY. I THINK THOSE
HEIRONEOUS- INTERRUPTION PLEASE
CONTINUE. APARTMENT SHOULD BE A
CONDUIT OTHERS AB FOR PROVIDING
THAT INFORMATION EXCEPT IN SO
FAR AS- IT WOULD CONFORM TO THE
MISSION STATEMENT- AND DISTANT
INCLUDED I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK- THE COMMITTEE AND- THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
MIGHT THERE BE ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM MANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE EITHER
IN THE CHAMBERS OR ON THE LINE
WITH ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE JOINING US.
VIA TELEPHONE OR VIDEO
CONFERENCE HAVE ANY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. OKAY HEARING NONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMISSIONERS FOR A TESTIFYING
WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WHEN I MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
REVIEW OF THE BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS. AND TODAY WE
ARE JOINED BY THE FOLLOWING
WITNESSES. JIM KIRK MAIER
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND LORETTA
DILLON DEPUTY CHIEF. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHATEVER
READY. AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN LOW
CHAIRMAN GLAZER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY FOR FIRE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. THE CHIEF OF
THE BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS ON HAS RETIRED
ACTUALLY IN JUNE SO I WILL BE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR THE
BUREAU. WITH ME TODAY IS
ALREADY DILLON IS THE DEPUTY
CHIEF ALSO FAILED TO TEACH-
WHO'S THE LEGAL COUNSEL FOR THE
GROWN UP THE THIRD ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RELAX WITH THIS
BODY TODAY. ON THE IMPORTANT
WORK OF THE BUREAU. IF YOU'RE A
LICENSES AND- REAL ESTATE. AND
REGISTER APPRAISAL MANNER
COMMITTEES AND- THE BUREAU AND-
FOR BY REGULATORY. THE BUREAU'S
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
ACCREDITATION OF EDUCATIONAL
COURSES AND I AM PROVIDE AND
COURSE PROVIDERS FOR A REAL
ESTATE APPRAISER LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION. THE BEER IS THE
BETTER THE SUNSET REPORT I'M
PROBABLY ALMOST ABOUT A YEAR
AGO ACTUALLY NOW I'M AND FREE
MISTER LAWRENCE AND FORMER
BUREAU CHIEF MARTIN'S
LEADERSHIP THE BUREAU HAS
REMAINED STEADFAST IN ITS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND REGULATING THE
BILL ESTATE INDUSTRY. THE
DEPARTMENT IMPAIR RECEIVED THE
DRAFT BACKGROUND ON PAPER FROM
THE MOVE ON NOVEMBER THIRTEENTH
AND THE FINAL VERSION OF
TUESDAY AND I REALLY WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
INTO NEW DILIGENCE DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES I THANK
THEM FOR THEIR WORK ON THESE
PAPERS. THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
BUREAU LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE DOING
DURING THE SUNSET PROCESS. ON
THE ISSUES IDENTIFIED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER IN THE MONTHS
THAT AT. THAT BEING SAID I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
ISSUES RAISED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER. EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY THE BUREAU
INCREASED FEES THROUGH
REGULATIONS FOR A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE. APPRAISER APPRAISAL
MANAGEMENT MANY REGISTRATION AT
HORSE PROVIDERS. FIRST ONE
BACKGROUND JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND THE BUREAU'S BUDGET
IS FUNDED SOLELY THROUGH FEES
CHARGED TO LICENSEES REGISTERED
FROM FORCED RIDERS. FACTORS
SUCH AS PUMP. AND EMPLOYER
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTION RATE
INCREASES FOR THE REALLY THE
MAIN CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO
THE BUREAU'S ANNUAL INCREASES
IN EXPENDITURES. IN ADDITION
THE BUREAU'S DRASTIC DECLINE OF
ITS APPRAISER LICENSEE
POPULATION. A TO A REDUCTION IN
REVENUE IN STATE IS ANOTHER
FACTOR DRIVING FACTOR PROJECT
CONTRIBUTING TO THE NEED FOR
THE THEME. APPAREL HAS LOST
MORE THAN HALF OF ITS LICENSE
APPRAISER POPULATION OVER THE
PAST DECADE. THE PRICE BE
STRUCTURE INCLUDED A
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS DATING BACK
TO THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND
STARTING IN. TWO THOUSAND TWO
ACTUALLY UP TO TWO THOUSAND
NINE LOANS WERE MADE TO THE
GENERAL FUND TOTALING AN AMOUNT
OF NINETY. SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THE BUREAU
TEMPLE EVERY REALLY REDUCE ITS
LICENSING. IT TO THE BUREAU'S
FISCAL PRUDENCE AND THE GENERAL
DIRECTOR FOR MARKET MAYBE IT
MAY BE A KILEY INTERRUPT YOU
DIFFER AMONG WE'RE HAVING A FEW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVING
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING YOU
THROUGH THE MASK I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS POSSIBLE PERHAPS TO A
NANCY EIGHT OR SPEAK MORE
SLOWLY- OR LOUDLY- WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE- GIVEN. WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCE YOU MIGHT BE AN-
OKAY YOU THANK WITH ALL. I WILL
WILL SPEAK LOW HAVE AT THAT.
SHE CLEARED IT IT MAY MAYBE IT
MAYBE IF THE IS A POSSIBLE YOU
THE SOLE PERSON IN THE ROOM TO-
I AM NOT THAT WE WILL TRY WE
CAN. SOCIAL DISTANCING HERE
WILL MOVE INDIVIDUALS AROUND
WHAT YOU'RE JUST HAVING A
REQUEST OF NO- AB TO CHECK YOUR
COMFORT LEVEL WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE COMFORTABLE-
BUT THOUGH. TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
YOU WOULD BE IDEAL. WE NEED.
WERE MOVING THE ROOM A
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT COMBINATION THANK YOU
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
UNDERSTAND. YOU CLEARLY
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS AND
YOU AND YOUR TEAM. THANK YOU.
THEY WOULD FEEL LIKE. I'M
BACKED UP ON TALKING ABOUT THIS
OR JUST. YEAH IF YOU IF YOU IF
YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND AND AGAIN
I THINK JUST GIVEN. SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WERE
TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE AND- BE
ABLE TO BEST HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SO. THANK YOU AGAIN IF
YOU COULD KINDLY ANNUNCI EIGHT
AND SPEAK LOUDLY. AND SLOWLY
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL THANK YOU.
OKAY GREAT- AGAIN IT JUST A
GOING BACK OVER THE BUREAU AND
WITH THAT IT DOES THE BUREAU
ACTUALLY LICENSES AND REGULATES
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS AND
REGISTERS APPRAISAL MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
BEER WAS ENTIRELY FUNDED BY
REGULATORY FEES AND THE GIRLS
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ACCREDITATION OF EDUCATIONAL
COURSES AND COURSE PROVIDERS
FOR A REALESTATE APPRAISER
LICENSING. AND CERTIFICATION.
THE BUREAU SUBMITTED A SUNSET
REPORT NEARLY A YEAR AGO AND
THREE MISTER LANDS AND FORMER
BUREAU CHIEF MARTIN'S
LEADERSHIP THE BUREAU HAS
REMAINED STEADFAST IN ITS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND REGULATING THE
REAL ESTATE APPRAISER INDUSTRY.
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE BUREAU
RECEIVED THE DRAFT BACKGROUND
PAPER FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
NOVEMBER THIRTEENTH. AND THE
FINAL VERSION ON TUESDAY AND WE
REALLY WANT TO THANK AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
CONTINUED DILIGENCE DURING
THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIME. AND
AGAIN JUST THANK THEM FOR THEIR
WORK ON ALL OF THE PAPERS. ZERO
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THE SUNSET
PROCESSON THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER IN THE MONTHS AHEAD.
HOWEVER WITH THAT BEIG SAID I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER. SO
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE BUREAU DID
INCREASE ITS FEES REGULATIONS
FOR APPRAISER LICENSING.
APPRAISAL A MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE REGISTRATION AND
COURSE PROVIDERS AS WELL. I
JUST GIVING YOU SOME BACKGROUND
ON THE NEXT ISSUE THAT AROSE
BUDGET IS FULLY FUNDED THROUGH
FEES CHARGED TO LICENSEES
REGISTRANTS AND COURSE
PROVIDERS. OF FACTORS SUCH AS
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND
EMPLOYER RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTION RATE INCREASES FOR
THE MAIN CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO
THE BUREAU'S ANNUAL INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURES. IN ADDITION
HEROES DRASTIC DECLINE OF ITS
APPRAISER LICENSING POPULATION
LEADING TO A REDUCTION IN
REVENUE INTAKE WAS ANOTHER
DRIVING FACTOR CONTRIBUTING TO
THE MEETING FOR THE FINANCING.
THE BUREAU HAS ACTUALLY LOST
MORE THAN HALF OF ITS LICENSED
APPRAISER POPULATION OVER THE
PAST DECADE. THE PRIOR FEE
STRUCTURE IN LOOTED A
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS DATING BACK
TO THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND TWO UP
TO TWO THOUSAND NINE ONE FOR
MADE TO THE GENERAL FUND AND
THEY HAVE TOTAL ABOUT NINETEEN
OINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THE BUREAU
TEMPORARILY REDUCED ITS
LICENSING FEES TO THAT SURPRISE.
YOU TO THE BUREAU'S FISCAL
PRUDENCE AND THE GENERAL FUND
LOAN REPAYMENT WITH INTEREST
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THE BUREAU WAS ABLE TO OPERATE
IN DID NOT ELIMINATE THE FEE
REDUCTION ACTUALLY UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. ALTHOUGH THE
GENERAL FUND LOAN REPAYMENTS
ALLEVIATED THE NEED FOR A FEE
INCREASE FOR THOSE YEARS THERE
STILL EXISTED A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN THE BOAT HEROES
BUDGET AND ONCE THE GENERAL
FUND LOAN REPAYMENTS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY PAID BACK. I AM AND
THE CASH INFUSION BASICALLY
STOP AT THAT POINT THE BUREAU
NEEDED TO RAISE FEES AND DID SO
VIA REGULATIONS IN JANUARY OF.
AND THAT'S WHAT LED UP TO ALL
OF THAT. OVER THE PAST YEARS
THE BUREAU REDUCE EXPENDITURES
AND IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL COST
SAVING MEASURES INCLUDING
ELIMINATING FIVE POSITIONS FOR
APPROXIMATELY 500-500-1000
DOLLARS. I'M IN ANNUAL SAVINGS
AND ALSO MOVED ITS OFFICE FROM
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. OUT TO
RANCHO CORDOVA FOR A SAVINGS OF
APPROXIMATELY. THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER EIGHT
YEARS. ZERO CONTINUES TO
MONITOR ITS REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURES CLOSELY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE THOSE COSTS.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL WORK WITH
THE BUREAU TO ENSURE THE BEER
WAS FUN CONDITION IS BEING
MONITORED VERY CLOSELY.
REGARDING NINETEEN AND ITS
IMPACT ON HERE I'M PLEASE I'M
APPROXIMATELY 75% OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AT THE BUREAU- OF
THE STAFF ARE ACTUALLY TELL
WORKING DURING THE SENATE. THE
BILL HAS NOT EXPERIENCED ANY
BACKWARDS AS A RESULT OF THE
WORK ENVIRONMENT CHANGES. OF
THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD A LIMITED
IMPACT ON REAL ESTATE APPRAISER
INDUSTRY HOWEVER THE BUREAU
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND
COMMUNICATE WITH STAKEHOLDERS
REPORT WE SHOULD THIS CHANGE.
IF YOU'RE HAS PROVIDED
INFORMATION TO AND COMMUNICATED
WITH ITS LICENSEES AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND COSUMERS
REGARDING OVER NINETEEN. AND
ACTUALLY EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
BUREAU PROVIDED FAQS IN GENERAL
GUIDANCE TO ITS LICENSEES AND
THEN ALSO PASSED ALONG
INFORMATION PUT OUT BY SISTER
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS THE
APPRAISAL FOUNDATION. THE
BUREAU ALL OFFERED LICENSEES
EXTENDED TIME TO COMPLETE MOST
OF THEIR CONTINUING EDUCATION
COURSES AT THE PIER WAS ABLE TO
DO THIS BECAUSE IT'S CONTINUING
EDUCATION LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WE ARE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
EXCEPT THE BUREAU HAS AN
ADDITIONAL. EDUCATION COURSE
I'M ONLY REFERRED TO AS A LAWS
AND REGULATIONS FORCE. AND WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALLOWED
FOR DETRIMENTS RENEWALS WITHOUT
COMPLETING CONTINUING EDUCATION
SO DID THE BUREAU SAID THEY
JUST WENT IN LINE WITH THE
FEDERAL AND WHAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL FOR TOO MANY.
HOWEVER THE BUREAU ALWAYS
REQUIRED TO LAWS AND
REGULATIONS FOR STREAMLINED
COURSE- BECAUSE REALLY THAT
SPECIFIC COURSES IN THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE AND THE BUREAU
DID NOT RECEIVE A WAIVER-
THEY'RE ACTUALLY EIGHT ZERO
THAT. I'M DOES NOT FIT INTO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT THEY
COULDN'T RECEIVE ANY WAIVERS
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON A FEW OF
THEM ISSUES RAISED. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
LEGISLATURE ON THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. AND AT
THIS TIME WE ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE- REGARDING THE BUREAU
AND AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME ON AND WORK ON THAT.
DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBER
OF ON TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CURRENTLY IN
THE CHAMBERS AT THIS TIME I
DEBATE ANY QUESTIONS FOR A FROM
COUNTY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
CHECK LATER. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR- I MUST SAY I STILL IT
WAS CHALLENGING TO- TO HEAR
YOUR TESTIMONY BUT I THINK I
GOT. MOST OF IT- LOOK AT THIS
THIS MOVE OF THE BUREAU- UNDER
DCA IS A POINT OF- OF A
PARTICULAR INTEREST. AND YOU
KNOW A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN RAISED AS TO WHETHER THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO OR NOT.
AND THE COSTS INVOLVED IN THE
IN THE MOVE. AND THE
EFFICIENCIES AND THE SERVICES.
AND SO THERE THESE ARE LL.
TIONS THAT ARE IN MY HEAD AND I
ADMIT WE DON'T MAYBE DON'T HAVE
TIME TO GET INTO ALL OF THEM
HERE AND I HOPE THAT STAFF WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. BUT I AM
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE
BENEFITS NOW TO- TO THE PREY
THROUGH THE REAL ESTATE
APPRAISAL COMMUNITY FOR THIS
CHANGE IN THIS MOVE AND- OUR
SERVICE IS BEING PROVIDED A
HIGHER QUALITY NOW AND IF SO
HOW SO- YOU KNOW WHAT
MEASUREABLE BENEFITS ARE WE
GETTING WHAT ARE THE ADDITIONAL
COSTS THEY WERE INCURRING. AND
ARE THEY REASONABLE. AND ARE
THERE REALLY EFFICIENCIES AND
WHAT ARE THAT. YOU'VE ADDRESSED
A FEW OF THEM IN TERMS OF
MOVING THE OFFICES AND- AND
THINGS SUCH AS THAT BUT- I AM
INTERESTED IN AND UNDERSTANDING
MORE DEEPLY- THESE ISSUES THAT
I'VE RAISED HERE WE WELCOMED IT
TO ADDRESS THEM AS YOU SEE FIT
NOW. BUT YOU KNOW YOU YOU'RE
YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF IT ALSO
THESE ARE THIS IS A BUREAU AND
YOU SAY YOU WANT THEM TO BE AND
EXACTLY WHERE THEY ARE SO THIS
IS NOT THE BEST NO I'M NOT
TALKING TO SOMEONE FROM THE
BUREAU. RIGHT SO. IT IS A- YEAH
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
CONFLICT THAT COMES INTO PLAY
WOULD YOU SAY. AND ACTUALLY I
DO HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE BUREAU
AND THAT WILL ALSO BE
RESPONDING. TO THAT SPECIFIC
ISSUE AS WELL IF YOU WOULD
LIKE- AND SO ONE THING I DO
WANT TO SAY IS WHEN THEY- THE-
HERO WAS ACTUALLY PART OF. THE
OF THE DEPARTMENT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY PAYING FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE SO
CHANGING THEM OVER- EVEN TO
THAT DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THEY STILL HAD TO PAY
FEES SO. THAT WAS A TRANSITION
SO EVEN IF THERE WAS A CHANGE
TO ANOTHER AREA THEY WOULD
STILL HAVE TO PAY FEES TO
SOMEONE WHO PROVIDES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE BEING PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. TO THE- BUREAU OF
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY WERE SO DO
YOU DO YOU WANT TO POINT THAT
OUT IT WASN'T. ALTHOUGH THE
FEES MAY HAVE INCREASED
SOMEWHAT FOLLOWING FROM WHERE
THEY #VIOUSLY
DEPARTMENT THERE THOSE THOSE
THINGS WOULD STILL HAVE TO
CONTINUE BUT I AM ACTUALLY
GONNA LET MYSTEEL IN RESPONSE
TO THE QUESTION AS WELL ABOUT
THE SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASED
EFFORT TO PROVIDE SERVICES. TO
THE BUREAU I'M COMMENSURATE
WITH. THE COST OF A PROGRAM.
YEAH THE NEW REALLY OF THE
EXPECTED TEAM CURRENTLY AT THE-
OF. AFFAIRS REALLY HAS HOW CAN
WE THE POOR AND BUREAUS
PROVIDING SERVICE THAT. REALLY
HAS BEEN A OF WITH MY OVER OKAY
AS THE- DIRECT. AND REALLY THAT
MEANS. FOR ME IT NEEDS CHANGING
I'M REALLY A MINDSET OF.
BASICALLY LOOKING AT- THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE THIS OVERSIGHT
AGENCY AND WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT YOU KNOW EVERYTHING.
FOLLOWED AND REALLY SOMETIMES
SAYING NO TO THE BOARDS AND
GIRLS REALLY MORE TO LOOKING AT
A TEAM RELATIONSHIP WORKING
TOGETHER WHERE WE AND- THEY-
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO BE DONE
THIS WAY BUT IS THERE ANOTHER
PATHWAY. TO MEET THE GOAL OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO FOR
THAT PARTICULAR ITEM. AND OF
COURSE THERE'S ALWAYS AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. WE ARE CONTINUING
TO WORK. ON SEVERAL OF THOSE
AREAS AND. IT WILL BE AN
ONGOING. GOAL FOR US HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO
IN THOSE SERVICES BUT I WILL
LET DELLA I'M BECAUSE- ON
SERVICES OF OUR- I'M WE WILL
GET BACK TO SENATOR WITH THE-
COMPLETE ANALYSIS OF. YOU KNOW
WITH THE FINE OF WHAT IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY IN WHAT IS NOW- AND
AGAIN ALL OF THE SERVICES YOU
KNOW THAT WE DO PROVIDING.
ISSUES OR SURROUNDING HUMAN
RESOURCES- BUDGETING- PERSONNEL
ACTIONS WHEN WE TAKE THEM AS
WELL AS- CONTRACTING AND ALL OF
THAT PROCESS WHICH AGAIN WAS
PROVIDED. BY THE DEPARTMENT
BEFORE THEY MOVED IN HAVE A
FEW. BUT MISTER ONE I WILL.
ALLOW HER TO. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES FOUR OKAY THANK YOU- TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION I MEAN
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
PROVIDES A VALUABLE SERVICE TO
US- THE SERVICES MANY OF THE
SERVICES HAVE IMPROVED OVER THE
FIVE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN WITH
THE BUREAU- AS- THIS KIRSCHNER
SAID THERE'S- CERTAINLY ROOM
FOR. ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENTS- I
CANNOT REALLY SPEAK TO THE
SERVICES THAT WE RECEIVED UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE I
WAS NOT- AROUND AT THAT TIME SO
MY ENTIRE TENURE HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSUMER FAIRS- SO. I THINK
THAT'S I'M NOT SURE THE ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION. WELL AT FIRST
THANK YOU BOTH THE DIRECTOR
INTO YOU- FOR ENGAGING. THESE
CONVERSATIONS CAN CONTINUE- YOU
KNOW THERE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
SUBSTANTIAL FEE INCREASES. AND-
THOSE THAT ALWAYS. PROMOTE A
DEEPER REVIEW OF- THE SERVICES
PROVIDED AND EFFICIENCIES OR
LACK THERE OF TO SO EVERYBODY
CAN BE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
AND I APPRECIATE THE- THE
ENGAGEMENT AS I SAID TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR GLAZER. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE
JOINING US REMOTELY AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO ASK A
QUESTION IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENT AS IT DID
AT THIS TIME. SENATE ARCHULETA
ME I JUMPED IN. SENATOR WELCOME
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU-
I'VE BEEN WATCHING AND
LISTENING AND I'VE JUST NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET IN BUT THANK
YOU TO THE TECHNICAL EFFORTS
THAT WE HAVE UP THERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE REMOTE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO OVER THE LAST-
THIRTY FORTY MINUTES I AM NOW
ABLE TO COME ON- I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO'S APPEARED
BEFORE TODAY. AND I I'M MY
QUESTION WITH THE- WITH THE
APPRAISAL. THE FACT IS THAT
THERE'S SO MUCH DEMAND RIGHT
NOW- FOR REFINANCING AND SO ON
HOW IS THE INDUSTRY HANDLING
THAT AND ARE DO YOU HAVE AN OUT
REACH FOR APPRAISERS THAT ARE
MORE IN JUNE TO A PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOOD THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE YOU
KNOW- YOU MAY HAVE A CERTAIN
SECTION OF THE CITY THAT- IS
SOMEONE WILL COME IN. FIFTY
MILES AWAY TO COMMAND AND DO AN
APPRAISER BUT HASN'T FULL
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AREA WHERE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND IT COULD BE
PRETTY HIGH RATHER THAN JUST
WHAT THE NUMBERS SHOW HOW ARE
YOU HANDLING THAT. THAT NEITHER
DURING OUTREACH PROGRAM DUE TO
MAKE IT MORE- I THINK- DIVERSE.
IT THE IN THE COMMUNITY. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE ABLE TO
HEAR ME YES WE ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER DIRECTOR KIRK
MAIER MY CHIU KILEY RESPOND TO
SENATOR ARCHULETA. NINE IF YOU
CLICK ON PROGRAM IS JUST ONE
MOMENT- HAVE AN- ITS MISSION
THURMOND AT ANSWER. THIS
QUESTION. THANK YOU. LOS'S
COUNTY OF EUROPE COUNCIL CAN
EVERYONE EVERYTHING I KNOW IF
YOU COULD KINDLY SPEAK LOUDLY
AND THEN SAY THAT BE GREAT.
LOS'S KILEY ATTORNEY FOR THE
BUREAU. I HEARD PART OF THE
QUESTION THE BEGINNING PART
WHICH IS HOW IS THE INDUSTRY
REACTED TO THE REFINANCE
INCREASE- I HEARD PART OF THIS
BY BELIEVED TO BE A SECOND PART
THE QUESTION. ABOUT LOCAL
EXPERTISE- REGARDING HOW THE
INDUSTRY IS REACTING- I CAN'T
SPEAK TOO MUCH FOR THE
INDUSTRY- AS WE REGULATE
APPRAISERS AND APPRAISAL
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES- I AM
AWARE OF THE INCREASED- AND
LIKELY MARKET FORCES ARE
ASSISTING AND- GETTING INCREASE
SERVICES WHERE POSSIBLE OF FOR
LOCAL EXPERTISE. APPRAISERS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE- THAT LOCAL
KNOWLEDGE WHEN THEY ARE DOING
THEIR APPRAISALS- SO THAT
SHOULDN'T BE AN ISSUE BUT AGAIN
I MISSED PROBABLY THE LAST HALF
OF THE QUESTION. IN THE SECOND
HALF OR THIRD HALF THAT.
PORTION OF THAT QUESTION IS THE
FACT THAT DIVERSITY IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW D.
BOARD LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE THAT
COME INTO THEIR GENERAL AREAS
THAT FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE COMMUNITY AND-
BATCH IMPORTANT AND THAT'S THAT
I'M I GUESS I'M ADDRESSING YOUR
OUTREACH PROGRAM TO. BRING
PEOPLE IN FROM THE COMMUNITIES-
TO PARTICIPATE AND BECOME A
LICENSED APPRAISERS. YES THERE
ARE- TRADITIONALLY IT IS A
SUPERVISOR TRAINEE RELATIONSHIP
WHICH GETS NEW BLOOD INTO THE
INDUSTRY- WERE EXCITED ABOUT
AND A NEW PROGRAM. THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEING ROLLED OUT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. W. FOR
DISAFFECTED AND- THAT IS GOING
TO TAKE- A DIFFERENT APPROACH
TO GAINING EXPERIENCE WHICH
AGAIN IS CURRENTLY ONLY-
GAINED. THROUGH GOING OUT
TYPICALLY WITH THE SUPERVISOR
AND GAIN EXPERIENCE NOW. WITH A
NEW TYPE OF EXPERIENCE. ALL ONE
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A
SUPERVISOR- THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
GO OUT AND- GAIN THAT
EXPERIENCE- THROUGH A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF PROGRAM TO- GET THEIR
FOOT IN THE DOOR. AND GET-
HOPEFULLY INCREASE DIVERSITY IN
OUR POPULATION- GOOD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR ARCHULETA ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME AGAIN.
AGAIN AT ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME. OKAY IT IS HEARING
NONE I DO HAD. HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY. TO DIRECTOR KURT
MEYER AND IT'S AGAIN BEEN
BROUGHT UP EARLIER WITH RESPECT
TO SPECIFICALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER
SIX WITH THAT SPECIFICALLY OF
FEE INCREASES BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF HAVING YOU JOIN
US AS A DIRECTOR YOU'RE WELL
AWARE AND FAMILIAR WITH THE
FACT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY APPROVED INCREASED
FEES ACROSS A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL ENTITIES THIS PAST
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. MUCH TO
OUR ANGST ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. I WANTED TO
GET SOME OF YOUR INSIGHTS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THAT. THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT HAS
BEEN PRESENTED BEFORE US ON THE
POTENTIAL INSOLVENCY. OF THE
BUREAU- SPECIFICALLY AND THE
NEED TO INCREASE FEES. AND YET
THE CONVERSATION CONCLUDING
AROUND TO SIMPLY INCREASING
FEES VERSUS THAT OF A
CONVERSATION AROUND
CONSOLIDATION OR ANY OTHER
AVENUES TO JUSTIFY THE
INCREASED BENEFITS SPECIFICALLY
DURING A COVERED PANDEMIC MY TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INSIGHTS TO THE FACT THAT.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATION ON CONTINUALLY
INCREASING FEES TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WITHOUT A CLEAR SPECIFIC
ARTICULATION OF AN INCREASE
BENEFIT AND OR- THE DIRECTION
TO FOCUS ON CONSOLIDATION OR
ALTERNATIVE METHODS. AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW FOR
THAT QUESTION- THIS IS AN
ISSUE- AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THAT WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT-
AMONGST OURSELVES. AND SOME OF
THE THINGS PARTICULARLY WITH
THIS BUREAU THAT THAT WE HAVE
WORK THAT IS FINDING WAYS WHERE
WE CAN ASSESS THE BUREAU- AND
FROM A FROM THE TCA'S
PERSPECTIVE- ONE AREAS IN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WHERE
WE'VE ACTUALLY LOOKED AT THAT
AT I'M AT THE ABILITY TO
CONSOLIDATE SERVERS AND I KNOW
THAT MAY SEEM. MINOR BUT EVERY
LITTLE BIT HELPS WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT WHERE AREAS TO
CONSOLIDATE IT- AND TO LOWER
COSTS FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WE HAVE WITH
THAT IS THEY ARE ALSO LOOKING
AT POTENTIALLY- THREE FIFTEEN
I'M MORE- STAFF. MEMBERS FOR
THAT. YOU'RE ALSO THAT WOULD
HELP WITH THEIR EXT. I'M I IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I OF REALIZE-
THAT. THE FEES A LOT OF THIS
WITH THE FEE INCREASES IS JUST
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS. AND
I HAD MENTIONED EARLIER IN MY
TALKING POINTS THE ISSUE OF HOW
IT HAS INCREASED- A BASED ON
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND THERE
HAVE BEEN INCREASES AND- DOES
IT OVER THE YEARS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AS TO WHERE YOU
HAD IN THE EARLY. REALLY IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND AND IN THOSE AREAS ALL
THE WAY UP UNTIL PROBABLY
ALMOST TWO THOUSAND. FOURTEEN
WE COULD NOT SEE THOSE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION INCREASES AND SO
THAT HAS REALLY IMPACTED- NOT
JUST ONLY THAT HERO. BUT IT
ALSO HAS IMPACTED I'M STATEWIDE
EMPLOYEES SO YOU HAVE ALSO
IMPACTED THE DEPARTMENT RIGHT
THERE'S EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS-
STATEWIDE. EMPLOYMENT AT
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE STATE. COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES SO WHEN YOU HAVE AN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION INCREASES
NOT ONLY IMPACT THAT THAT
SPECIFIC VERO BUT THE IMPACT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH- TO DISOBEY
PROBLEMATIC. APPS AND STATE
WIDE PROGRAM AT F. AND M. I
JUST YES I WOULD I WOULD LIKEN
IT TO- WHERE WE WERE FIVE YEARS
AGO MAYBE WHEN YOU. WENT OUT TO
A RESTAURANT AND YOU ACTUALLY
PAY THE BILLS THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT I WOULD STAY WHERE IT
IS TODAY. BECAUSE AS WE'VE ALSO
RAISED A MINIMUM WAGE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
IT'S NOT JUST THE SERVER THAT
YOU'RE INCREASING THEIR FEES
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE- ACTUAL.
HOPE THAT MAYBE LOOKING YOUR
MAIL THAT ALSO INCREASE BUT
ALSO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
BROUGHT ME TO THE NEAREST
RESTAURANT BUT IT'S ALSO THAT
INDIVIDUAL FRIEDMAN PRODUCE
SELF. IT WAS IT IF ALL OF THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE A EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION INCREASE IN IMPACT
ALL OF THAT ENHANCE THERE'S
JUST AN INCREASE. TO LOOKING AT-
REALLY THOSE THOSE BE INCREASES
SO THAT IT'S- IT BUT THING
INCREASE THE ALWAYS. THAT WE
WANT TO AT LAW THE FOR THING WE
WANT TO AT IT AS ARE THERE IF.
WE CAN. WILL BE THERE TO. IN
THE WAY DO THIS SUCH AND FROM
THE TECHNOLOGY ARE THE MORE
THAT WE PUT ON. SO WE ARE AND-
SYSTEM ACTUALLY- PROCESS OF THE
OUTPUT. AND THERE'S NOT AS MUCH
INFO WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE. I'M
ARE THERE OTHER WAY THAT WE CAN
FIND AND FISHING. IN HOW WE IN
FOR- ARE THERE. EVEN FOR. THAT
WE CAN- THAT INDIVIDUAL DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE A LOOK HARPER AND
THEY'RE GOING UP WHEN THAT'S
THE- THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A DEPARTMENT
WIDE NOT JUST FOR THE BUREAU
BUT- I'M JUST. THERE FOR THE
ONES AT THAT WHERE WE CAN FIND
EFFICIENCIES THAT CUT DOWN ON
THE PROCESS- AS WELL AS- MAKING
THAT. IS THE LAST THING I DO
HAVE TO SAY IT YES ONE OF THOSE
THINGS FOR THE SMALLER BUREAUS
IMPORTS THAT IS GREAT ARE
IMPACTED WHEN YOU DO HAVE THE
LOWER- PAUL YOUNG OF LICENSE
FEES AND WE SEE THIS ALSO
ACTUALLY IN THE BORDER PUT YES.
THAT WOULD BE AFTER MEDICAL
BOARD WE ALSO SEE THIS WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
PAYROLLS- WE ARE THERE ANY HAVE
HIGHER- ACTUALLY LICENSING FEES
BECAUSE THE LOWER. WITH EACH
OKAY THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY NEED
TO HELP THEM FIND WAYS WHERE WE
CAN- PROVIDE THEM THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED TO TRY TO PEOPLE
UP. FOR THANK YOU THERE ARE A-
I I'VE- THE- EXPLANATION WERE.
TO THE JUDGE THE- ON FEEDING.
OF AND- WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING YOU HERE TO HAVE A- HAVE
YOU HERE AND HAVE DIALOGUE.
THIS AS YOU KNOW I. HAVE SIR IN
DIFFICULT. TO FEED THESE BOARDS
COME BACK NOW FOR THE FALL
SUNSETS. AND MINIMIZE
EXPERIENCE. IT SUCH THAT. THE
CONCLUSION YOU'VE ARTICULATED
THAT IT'S NOT BUT THE FEW
CREASE IS NOT THE FIRST ROUTE.
BUT IN MY EXPERIENCE. IT SEEMS
TO BE THAT WE STILL CONCLUDE
AND MAKE THE DECISION THAT
THERE IS A FEE INCREASE FOR A
NUMBER OF THESE ENTITIES A
NUMBER THESE BOARDS. AND THE
QUESTION AGAIN IT OUTLINED. IN
PREPARATION OF THIS IN ISSUE
NUMBER SIX IS THAT. WHAT IS THE
JUSTIFICATION IT IS THERE AN
INCREASED WORKLOAD SPECIFICALLY.
TO JUSTIFY AN INCREASE OF
FIFTEEN CREE. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE LOOK AT WE HAD WE COULDN'T
DO AT THE INCREASE THAT'S GOING
TO BE COMING TO YOUR I'M FORTY
INCREASED IN- STATUTORY- THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE FEES WE
REALLY HAVE TO DO WITH THE
STUDY WHERE THAT COMES DIçN
AND A LOOK AT WHAT IT'S ASKING
TO DO THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND- JUST TO THE POINT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW TO THE-
IMPACT OF. INCREASES AS FAR AS-
YOU KNOW COMING. I SAY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BUREAU YOU KNOW THE
HADN'T REYES AND FEES FOR A
SIX. AMOUNT OF TIME BECAUSE
THEY HAVE LOWER. AND- IT WASN'T
THAT THE PROPERTIES AT TO WHERE
THEY WERE BEFORE AND SO I THINK
IT WAS INTO EIGHTEEN AND THAT
THEY BROUGHT THEM UP TO WHERE
THEY COULD BE IMPARTED TO THEM
BEING REDUCED. AND THEN THEY
BROUGHT THEM FORWARD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY- TO
RAISE THEM UP TO THEIR- MORE
TOWARDS THEIR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. SO I DIDN'T GET
IT IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME FOR
THIS ZERO- FOR THEM TO INCREASE
THEIR FEES. AND THAT AGAIN IS
WHAT WE LOOK AT- EIGHT I
UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO LOOK AT.
WHAT HAS BEEN INCREASED IN MAY
BE MANDATORY ISSUES FOR THE-
BOARDS OF GIRLS TO LOOK AT SO
HAS THERE BEEN THAT- BILL THAT
HAS PASSED. OR MAYBE THEY NEED
TO DO MORE. MORE APT. AND SO
HAVE TO AT THAT BUT THAT IS
WHOLE. FOR DOING A FEE ON THAT
STUDY FOR THE BOARD TO SET.
WHERE THOSE THINGS ARE FROM AND
WE WILL DIE. GO BACKFOR THIS
PARTICULAR BUREAU AND PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION AND- I'M ESTO
WHAT IMPACT. REQUIREMENT FOR
THIS. SO AGAIN I DID
SPECIFICALLY IT THE ANSWER THE
QUESTION IT HAS THERE BEEN AN
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD. AND FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BOARD I DON'T
BELIEVE SO BECAUSE OUR BUREAU I
NEED THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD A DEEP LYING AND-
THEIR ACTUAL- LICENSURE AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE IF I
REMEMBER LOOKING. ENFORCEMENT
DATE I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S AN
INCREASE A PRETTY STAYED PRETTY
STEADY ON THEIR ENFORCEMENT AND
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS COMING
AND THAT. ON DATA THAT HAS BEEN
COMING IN FROM OUR COMPANY
THANKS DAD STATE STEADY EVEN
THOUGH THE LICENSES- HAS
ACTUALLY GONE. OKAY THOSE THE
SPECIFIC ANSWER FROM YOU IS
THAT THERE IS NOT. AN INCREASE
IN WORKLOAD AND AG AGAIN YOU
WE'VE WE'VE OUTLINED HERE THAT
OF. THE DECREASING LICENSEE
POPULATION. SO ON THE SURFACE
ONE COULD SAY IT'S OFF A
COUNTER. INTUITIVE TO INCREASE.
THE FEES FOR A DECREASING THE
LICENSEE POPULATION AND PERHAPS
WE MIGHT LOOK AT CONSOLIDATION
AS AGAIN ADDRESSED IN ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. VERSES THAT OF.
DEFAULTING TO FEE INCREASES TO
WHICH I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE DEAL WITH
ALSO IN THE LEGISLATIVE BODY AS
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES IS
SOMETIMES THE STATE BUREAUCRACY
CANNOT SEEM IN TOUCH WITH THAT
OF THE REALITIES THAT EXIST
WITH EVERYDAY HARD WORKING
PEOPLE. AND THAT WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT OR EVEN THE
CONVERSATION AROUND FEE
INCREASES A SIGNIFICANT
FRUSTRATION THAT GOVERNMENT IS
NOT WORKING FOR PEOPLE AND THAT
I THINK IS PART OF THE DUTY
THAT WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY AND
WORKING WITH YOU AND WORKING
WITH OUR LICENSEES TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE. EFFECTIVE AND THAT
WERE WORKING TO SERVE THE
LICENSEE POPULATION. AND AGAIN
THE FRUSTRATION BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING YOU IS
THAT. ESPECIALLY IN THIS
CLIMATE. IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE
SPEECH INCREASES. GIVEN THE
CLIMATE AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
AGAIN WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
CAN TELL THEY WORK TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE AS EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE AND ESPECIALLY FOR
NOT ARTICULATING AND ENHANCED
TO BENEFIT OR VALUE. I THINK IT
IS INCUMBENT UPON US THEN TO
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO.
EFFECTUATE CHANGE IN A POSITIVE
FASHION AND NOT TO PUT THE
BURDEN ON THAT OF THE
LICENSEES- BUT AGAIN I KNOW
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CONVERSATIONS. BUT I WOULD JUST
URGE YOU TO ASSIST US IN
COLLABORATION AND ENSURING THAT
WE ACTUALLY. COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION BECAUSE THUS FAR MY
EXPERIENCE. WE CONTINUALLY SEEK
INCREASES AND LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES HAVE CONTINUOUSLY
SHARED THEIR RESERVATIONS. IN
IN SIMILAR. CONVERSATION AS
WELL SO. I HOPE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD AND AGAIN THAT WAS ON
ISSUE NUMBER SIX THAT WE'VE HAD.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO. PROVIDE ANY TESTIMONY AT
THIS TIME. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO TO COMMENT
VIA THE PHONE. THE YOU HAVE ONE
I'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. AND AS A
REMINDER ONE THEN ZERO TWO
COMMENTS. IN THE YEAR LOCAL TO
LINE IF TEAM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEVIN GLAZER AND TERMINAL- THIS
IS MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
APPRAISAL INSTITUTE I WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DILIGENCE ON
THE SUNSET REVIEW EFFORT AND
COMPLEMENT THE STAFF FOR A VERY
THOROUGH REPORT. I'D LIKE TO-
PASS A COMPLIMENT DIRECTOR KIRK
MYERS SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN OPEN
ACCESSIBLE AND FORTHRIGHT WITH
US AND WE APPRECIATE. THERE IS
BOTH A LONG TERM AND SHORT TERM
ISSUE THOUGH CONCERNING THE
BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS. STRUCK THERE'S A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM THAT
THREATENS TO BECOME A DEATH
SPIRAL FOR THE BUREAU- WHEN
CREATED IN NINETEEN NINETY AND
CONTINUOUSLY SENDS. APPRAISERS
ARE LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE COUNTRY ONLY TO
PERFORM WHAT ARE KNOWN AS
FEDERALLY RELATED APPRAISALS.
THOSE ARE GENERALLY LOANS MADE
BY FEDERALLY REGULATED LENDERS
IF I LOAN MONEY TO A NEIGHBOR
FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS NOT A
FEDERALLY RELATED TRANSACTIONS.
THE APPRAISAL CAN BE PERFORMED
BY ANYONE- WITH- WITHOUT A
LICENSE AND WITHOUT ANY
PARTICULAR STANDARDS. THE
GROWTH IN APPRAISAL OVER THE
THIRTY YEARS SINCE WE'VE
CREATED THIS LAW HAS BEEN IN
NON FEDERALLY RELATED
TRANSACTIONS THINGS LIKE. THAT
EXPERT WITNESS OR PORTFOLIO
REVIEW- ALSO ATTENTION OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NOT
GENERALLY RELATED AND THEREFORE
DO NOT REQUIRE A LICENSE. THAT
IS PART OF THE REASON FOR THE
DECLINE IN LICENSING NUMBERS
THE OTHER MAJOR REASON IS THE
INCREASED USE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
VALUING REAL ESTATE- THAT THAT
IS A TREND THAT IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE. THERE IS NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT LICENSE THE
NUMBERS WILL INCREASE SO YOU
YOU REALLY RUN INTO THIS
POTENTIAL OF A REGULATORY
SPIRAL WHERE FEWER AND FEWER
PEOPLE ARE PAYING MORE AND
MORE. FOR THEIR LICENSES WHICH
WILL CREATE A DISINCENTIVE TO
HELP ONE. AND THAT'S A LONG
TERM STRUCTURAL ISSUE THAT I
REALLY. THANK NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. THERE'S ALSO A SHORT
TERM ISSUE ON SEASON WE
APPRECIATE- THE BOTH CHAIRS
QUESTIONS AND- AND PROBING ON
THIS POINT. IN FACT APPRAISAL
LICENSE FEES ARE AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT- THE THREE NOW FOR A
RENEWAL OF THE GENERAL
CERTIFICATE IS A THOUSAND AND
THIRTY DOLLARS- IT IS HIGHER IS
AGAIN I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON
EVERY PROFESSIONAL THREE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S HIGHER THAN
LAWYERS FOR EXAMPLE- IT IS A
VERY SUBSTANTIAL FEE. AND
ADDITIONALLY- BUILDING I'M NOT
AT ALL SURE- AND WE'VE TALKED
TO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THIS IN
THE BUREAU BUT I'M NOT AT ALL
SURE THAT THE FEES. BEING
ASSESSED TO LICENSEES. ARE
AUTHORIZED BY THE STATUTE- A
LICENSE AS I INDICATED PAYS A
THOUSAND AND THIRTY DOLLARS.
FOR A RENEWAL THE LICENSING FEE
CHART INDICATES THAT THAT IS A
COMBINATION OF AN APPLICATION
REVIEW SEE AN ISSUE AND SPREE
AND VARIOUS REGISTRATION FEES-
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE STATUTE
THAT AUTHORIZES AN APPLICATION
REVIEW FEE AT IT AND IN FACT
THAT FEE WAS INCREASED FROM ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS TO FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS RECENTLY. AGAIN
WITHOUT AS FAR AS I CAN TELL
ANY STATUTORY AUTHORITY
WHATEVER IF YOU LOOK AT B. AND
T. SECTION ELEVEN FOUR OH FIVE
IT SAYS THAT THE C. FOR
ORIGINAL OR RENEWAL
CERTIFICATION IS FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS- AND THAT
IS REFLECTED IN THE LICENSING
FEE CHART BUT THERE IS NO
STATUTE THAT SAYS ANYTHING
ABOUT AN APPLICATION REVIEW
THREE. SO WE BROUGHT THAT UP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
BUREAU THEY ASSURED US THAT IT
WAS AUTHORIZED BY LAW BUT WE
DON'T SEE WHERE THAT IS. AND SO
YOU KNOW THERE'S BOTH A SHORT
TERM CLARIFICATION THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING AND THEN A LONG TERM
NEED TO LOOK AT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE REGULATORY PROGRAM
BECAUSE YOU THERE IS NO REASON
TO EXPECT A- A REBOUND IN
LICENSING NUMBERS. AND SO THE
FEE WILL JUST CONTINUE TO GO UP
FOR FEWER AND FEWER PEOPLE WHO
ARE VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO IT AND KNOW THAT
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF A
DIALOGUE. BUT THAT LACK OF
STATUTORY AUTHORITY IS A MATTER
OF QUITE SOME CONCERN FOR OUR
MEMBERS. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE YOU
VERY MUCH MY BELOW. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN OF THE
LINE FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK ASK
A QUESTION OR COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. YEP AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU DO HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT YOU CAN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO THE
QUESTION OR COMMENT. AND WE'RE
SHOWING NO ONE AND TWO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR MANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME AS
WE CONCLUDE. THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING SPECIFICALLY. ANY
MEMBERS WHO ARE JOINING US
REMOTELY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. OKAY
HEARING THEN THEN THAT'LL
CONCLUDE OUR HEARING ON THE
BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS WE THANK THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED AGAIN AS WILL
CONTINUE TO FLUSH OUT
ADDITIONAL OUTSTANDING ISSUES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AGAIN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THIS IS A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS TO WHICH
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF PUBLIC
MEETINGS TO ENSURETHE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND INPUT. AS WE LOOK TO ENSURE
TO ADDRESS MANY OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AS WE HEAD
INTO THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE
SESSION- WELL NOW- IF THERE'S
NO OTHER COMMENTS HERE IN THE
IN THE CHAMBERS- THAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR OVERSIGHT HEARING
THANK YOU.